Guten Morgen Linos.
Guten.
Herbst zieht ein, wird ganz schön kalt.
Dir doch einen schönen warmen Hoodie oder einen Zipper.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer vierhundertundzwölf vom zwölften elften zwanzig einundzwanzig und Einsen sind da drin. Ähm,
und dieses Karneval Karneval.
Nicht letzte gestern.
Was? Ja.
Einfach Karneval.
Er hat angefangen und jetzt ist die ganze Zeit Karneval. Es ist einfach eine fortgesetzter Dauerzustand, ein ein Grundgefühl, der permanent eine Erheiterung, auch wenn die Zeiten eigentlich düster,
eigentlich sehr gut zu unserem Programm, finde ich. Wir sind eigentlich Dauerkarte.
Äh hast du es mitbekommen, dass der diese Kölner Karnevalsjäcken äh die haben wir direkt mal für die für die Lachermeldungen des Tages gesorgt, weil ihr Prinz da Corona hat, ne?
Ja.
Er hatte noch irgendwie äh groß erzählt, ne, Corona und so. Das ist ja alles gar kein Thema für uns, ne. Und jetzt ist das komplette Dreigestirn da in Quarantäne. Ey, was sind das schon?
Und weißt du wer auch, wer auch äh Corona hat?
Alice Weidel.
Oh ja, da müssen wir auch noch mal gute Besserung wünschen. Hoffentlich, weil, also ich meine, du, äh ungeimpft ähm,
hört man, dass das gar nicht so eine lustige Krankheit ist, ne.
Ja, habe ich auch gehört. Das könnte könnte tatsächlich zu Problemen führen. Aber das wollen wir ja nicht.
Ja da wollen wir mal hoffen, dass da nichts passiert, ey. Das wäre ja peinlich eigentlich, ne. Ja, ne.
Schicksale sind damit verbunden.
Na ja ähm ja gut, hätte natürlich auch Alfa eine Maske tragen können oder sich impfen lassen. Äh aber na ja.
Ich meine, das ist ja einfach, ich meine, da weiß man ja nicht so genau, weiß doch, wie's.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, da weiß man nicht, ne,
äh ähm ich meine andererseits man muss natürlich auch, ne, seiner Gefolgschaft halt mal als äh Führerin äh stramm vorangehen und sagen, alles klar, rein in die vierte Welle, meine Freunde,
So, ne? Wir lassen uns hier nicht bevormunden.
Wir lassen's vom überhaupt nicht. Verbieten. Ähm nee, ist doch super.
Das wird das sind das sind nur politische Vorbilder die wir brauchen.
Ja, das sind so Politlämminge.
Vor allem auch, weißt du, wenigstens trinken die das Wasser, was sie predigen, ja? Muss man ja auch mal sagen.
Auch wenn's ein bisschen verseucht ist.
Ja. Nee, aber echt schade, alle gute Besserung an Alice Weidel, ne? Nicht, dass da jetzt was passiert. Ähm so, dann haben wir ähm.
Mit etwas Verspätung haben sich auch sehr viele drüber beschwert, aber so ist das. Gut Ding will Weile haben den äh Shirt-Shop gelauncht.
Zwar nicht nur mit Shirts. Ähm bei unseren Freunden von Ticket-Toaster
gibt es äh T-Shirts mit Logbuch Netzpolitik Logo, alles schwarze Klamotten
relativ einfacher Grund. Ich trage nur schwarz, also gibt's nur schwarz. Aber ihr könnt euch ähm äh sicherlich mal ein Ticket-Toaster wenden, weil solange sich nicht groß also so lange sich nicht an dem,
Druckmotiv etwas ändert und an der Druckfarbe,
Ist das jetzt nicht so ein Problem, da vielleicht mal eine andere Shirtfarbe noch mit reinzulegen, so sieht denn vorrätig ist.
Ja? Da könnt ihr äh euch mal bei denen melden. Das Gleiche gilt sollten es dort Textile geben, die nicht ähm.
In eurer Größe vorrätig sind, äh dann wendet euch einfach mal an die und dann könnt ihr euch sagen, was äh möglich zu machen ist und was nicht.
Ist ja jetzt auch erstmal so eine Phase, ne. Wir haben jetzt sozusagen die äh ihr wollt es unbedingt vor Weihnachten haben, meinetwegen, dann bitte bis zum 28.11. bestellen. Ähm,
Ich denke, wir werden auch darüber hinaus noch eine Versorgung betreiben und ich nehme grade mit größtem Interesse äh auf, was sozusagen vielleicht sonst noch so gewünscht ist und da wurde schon sehr viel Einhornstandarte äh fallengelassen, dass natürlich
richtig, das haben wir in gewisser Hinsicht vollkommen äh verpennt. Ähm da werden wir dann auch noch ähm nachbessern
und äh insofern bitte bitte bitte äh Feedback über äh alle erdenklichen äh Kanäle.
Ihr denn noch so gerne äh hättet, äh bezieht sich halt auf Farben, auf Formen und auf Inhalte und da ist äh noch einiges zu holen. Das war jetzt einfach alles ein bisschen,
fiel auf einmal und äh musste erstmal irgendwie alles aus der Tür. Und insofern geht's dann noch weiter.
Würde da gerne noch kurz etwas ergänzen, weil ich das immer wieder den Leuten erkläre. Ich mache diesen äh Produktionskram ja seit einiger Zeit auch für den CCC. Ähm also in diesem Fall ist es so, die Bestellungen sind bis zum 28.11. möglich,
Und dann werden diese Dinge produziert, so ungefähr in der ersten Dezemberwoche und dann werden sie versendet. Also es wird also nicht möglich sein,
das äh nachzuproduzieren und zu sagen, ah ich bestell mal am neunundzwanzigsten noch eins, könnt ihr doch auch noch eben machen, ja? Ähm das wird,
so ohne Weiteres nicht möglich sein und das hat mit der Fertigungslogistik zu tun, da das eben ein Siebdruckverfahren ist und man macht halt Eindruck durchlauf für alle.
Ja? Und es ist quasi einfach ökonomisch nicht abbildbar. Wenn da jetzt jemand sagt, ich habe hier mein Motiv, mach mal bitte ähm.
Mach mal bitte nur ein Shirt damit. Ja, das kostet dann halt so viel wie 50 oder 1hundert zu machen, weil der größere Aufwand eben das Einrichten dieser Druck äh ein,
Einrichtung ist und äh das ist auch ein bisschen der Grund, warum wir jetzt erstmal eine nicht unendliche Anzahl Motive machen.
Weil die Konsequenz natürlich auch sein könnte, dass dann irgendwelche Motive
nur sehr wenig gekauft werden und es sich dann wieder nicht sinnvoll abbilden lässt. Insofern,
ähm ja, jetzt bitte darauf achten bis zum 28. und es ist äh denkbar, dass wir dann daraus erkennen, okay, was was was möchten die Leute haben, was nicht? Und dass wir dann potenziell auch mal in eine Situation gehen, wo wir,
quasi vorproduzieren.
Und weil wir einfach wissen, okay, so ungefähr ist die Nachfrage, das kriegen wir ungefähr weg und äh dann nehmen wir sicherlich auch im nächsten Jahr nochmal vielleicht mit anderen Motiven,
diese diese Sache,
auf uns. Aber es ist eben nicht irgendwie Spreadshirt oder sonst was, wo wo im Billigdruckverfahren äh auf auf Chinatextil gedruckt wird, sondern das möchte ich auch noch mal betonen,
Ja, je nachdem, was ihr da bestellt, äh ist äh sowieso irgendwie äh vegan, bio Fairware, CO2 reduziert.
Peter approve vegan, ja? Äh bedruckt in Deutschland ähm beim Mittelständler. So, also man kann,
glaube ich kaum was feineres.
Und Stoff produziert in Europa. Muss man nochmal dazu sagen. Ja, Portugal.
Stoff ist auch noch aus Europa. Genäht, ne? Also die ich ich weiß nicht, ob der ob die Baumwolle.
Die Baumwolle selber jetzt nicht, aber ist sozusagen auch die die Fertigung des Textils ist sozusagen in Europa, kommt aus äh Portugal und das ist halt auch ein Grund, warum das eben
nicht unbedingt jetzt zu äh südasiatischen Discountpreisen übern Tisch geht, sondern halt so zu etwas äh höheren Lohnkosten.
Genau, das ist der, das ist aber ein Standard, den wir beim äh CCC auch schon immer äh definiert haben. Und das geht, muss man natürlich auch dazu sagen, äh zu Lasten äh.
Der Marge und und gleichzeitig auch der Preise. Ja, schon irgendwie die ersten gehört, die sich beklagen, äh dass äh die T-Shirts, was kosten die?
Dreißig oder was? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Also wir haben 30 für die Shirts und 55 für die äh Hoodies und ich glaube 60 für diese Zipper.
Da ist äh erstaunlich äh also wenn man überlegt, dass wir natürlich auch etwas dafür bezahlen, dass es an euch versendet wird, gelagert wird, produziert wird und so weiter. Bleibt da nicht so viel Geld übrig, ja? Ähm insofern,
war das tatsächlich, als ich letzte Woche scherzte, ihr könnt für uns äh Werbung machen und müsst dafür bezahlen. Äh durchaus äh.
Nee, das äh aber es gab auch viel Bereitschaft in dieser Hinsicht. Das fand ich irgendwie ganz gut.
Sich in den Dienst der Werbung äh für äh Logbuchnetzpolitik zu stellen. Was generell äh eine gute Idee ist, wie ich finde, äh was so den Podcast an sich betrifft, egal auf ob's auf der Straße visuell zur Schau getragen wird oder in irgendeiner Form audiovisuell durchs Internet,
oder als Text oder was auch immer.
Genau, ihr könnt äh also ihr könnt uns immer gerne weiterempfehlen, zum Beispiel auch wenn man hat das ja manchmal im Sommer mehr als im Winter bis irgendwo auf der Straße, dir ist langweilig, kannst du eigentlich auch einfach mal weiterempfehlen. Ja, Lauf wäre genug Leute rum.
Das T-Shirt anziehen, genau. Man kann uns empfehlen, man kann positive Bewertungen hinterlassen,
höre ich immer, ich weiß nicht genau wo, aber bei iTunes oder so, ne.
Ja ja. Also ich will jetzt gar nicht in dieses äh Klick hier Like hier äh Business abdriften, da bist du,
Bei mir äh zieht sich immer so ein bisschen der Magen äh zusammen, weil äh
diese permanente ähm Instrumentalisierung der Community finde ich dann auch irgendwie immer ein bisschen anstrengend, aber offensichtlich äh scheint es ja mittlerweile äh so weit plattformisiert zu sein, dass das sozusagen der Algorithmus ist.
Nimmt keiner mehr ernst, Tim, wenn du das nicht machst.
Na ja.
Wenn du nicht sagst, äh äh Subscribe, Glocke, like, äh folgt meiner Instagram-Story oder so, dann denken die, du bist irgendein Amateur.
Mhm. Mhm. Ich bin ja auch ein Amateur. Ich liebe das, was ich tue. Verstehst du? Mir geht's ja nicht nur ums Geld. Mir geht's nur auch ums Geld. Das ist was ganz anderes.
Genau, wenn ihr also Logbuch Netzpolitik unterstützen wollt, finanziell, dann ist die Spende immer noch der der äh ja äh der finanzielle Weg, ja? Die Shirts machen wir
eher, weil wir selber gerne welche haben und weil wir möchten, dass hier endlich mal was Ordentliches anhabt und äh dass ihr nicht friert im Winter, ja, weil,
uns ist die Community ja wichtig. Wenn ihr äh ansonsten gibt's noch äh in den Shownotes auch einige Links, wie man es auf äh anderen Wegen eine Freude machen kann. Ich habe ja zum Beispiel so einen Wunschzettel, wo ich Dinge drauf tue, über die ich mich freue.
Übrigens nicht mehr, weil ich da auch äh warum nicht ganz einfach, weil.
Du hast alles, ne?
Ich ich habe alles, ja, insofern, ich brauche nicht noch mehr Quatsch. Also ich habe wirklich äh ich bin das ganze Jahr über nur damit beschäftigt gewesen,
Wohnung und vor allem dieses Studio zu entrümpeln. Ich bin Dauergast auf eBay derzeit und ich verkaufe gerade alles, was irgendwie äh nicht den ähm wie das wie ist das bei Frau Kondo?
Ähm was mich nicht beschwingt irgendwie.
Genau äh und dann gab's eine ganze Menge, was nicht mehr sehr viel Joy ausgelöst hat und das geht irgendwie alles auf auf eBay oder ich stell's einfach auf die Straße und so, weil ab und zu braucht man im Leben auch mal so eine.
Aber jetzt das ist aber das hören aber die Leute gerne, die dir was geschenkt haben, Tim, da freuen die sich aber jetzt, dass sie dass ihre Geschenke gekonnt werden.
Ja also wenn wenn hier eine wenn hier eine Kiste mit Lebkuchen auftaucht.
Sagen wir mal so, die Person, die dir das Buch von Marie Kondo geschenkt hat, freut sich auf jeden Fall am meisten.
Ich brauche einfach nicht noch mehr Tante also so dieses äh äh klar, wenn man mal ich kaufe mir das dann lieber selber und gezielt und in dem Moment, wo ich's brauche
so und insofern diese Dauerspenden, sie haben einfach diesen beruhigenden Faktor, man sieht so, ah okay, es gibt da so ein gewisses Commitment
ist das, womit man planen kann, das das gibt einem irgendwie auch so ein äh ruhiges, wohliges Gefühl und das ist ja das, was wir alle haben wollen.
Andere Leute gehen dafür arbeiten, Tim, aber.
Ach so ja, ich mache so was ja gar nicht,
Habe ja nur bis bis gestern Nacht um zwei noch irgendwie da äh gesessen und irgendwie,
rausgehauen. Also äh wie auch immer ihr ihr kennt eure Optionen und nochmal der Hinweis, das Spendenkonto hat sich leider geändert. Wenn ihr einen Dauerauf
bitte, bitte, bitte äh den Aufwand noch mal treiben, Online-Banking zu betreiben und das zu ändern. Das ist teilweise nicht so schön. Ich weiß, aber es wäre jetzt wirklich wichtig, denn Ende dieses Monats,
wird dieses andere Konto aufgelöst und viele haben das schon gemacht, ein paar.
Gehört, du hast, du hast auch du hast ähm ähm äh ja ich hab's auf Twitter gelesen, du hast den Leuten allen äh Geld überwiesen, um in den Kontoauszügen zu landen, ne?
Also du hast äh quasi also das ist, sage ich mal, die die einzige Podcast-Unterstützung mit Dividende.
Ist so.
Ja wir haben dann bloß manche Leute auf das neue Konto irgendwie den einen Cent wieder zurück überwiesen, für den ich dann zehn Cent Bankgebühren bezahlen muss. Von daher ist das so Mitte,
bisschen schwierig. Also einfach nur umschälen reicht. Äh reicht, ne? So und.
Also hatte ich ich glaube, das hatte ich ja in der letzten Sendung schon erzählt, dass wir das von dass wir das bei PayPal ausprobiert haben. Ja,
also ein Cent überwiesen bei PayPal, dann sagt PayPal dir, ey, du hast einen Cent bekommen. Gebühr einen Cent. Also null,
und ich glaube, bei sechsunddreißig oder siebenunddreißig Cent beginnt der Moment, wo du am Ende einen Cent hast, ja,
Hätten wir auch nachlesen können, aber weil irgendwie lustiger äh am Tisch zu sitzen so mach mal vier, mach mal acht, mach mal sechzehn, Scheiße, nochmal zwei, drei, das kann doch nicht sein. Mach mal vierzig. Oh, kommt was an. So äh halt ähm,
Das ist das ist äh diese Gebühren sind sehr interessant und äh man kann natürlich auch mal gucken, wo so äh zum Beispiel die AfD ihre Konten hat und mal schauen, ne, für wie viel Geld man.
Der Emplification Faktor von zehn,
Der macht das unter Umständen sinnvoll, so einen Laden halt einfach mal zu ruinieren, ne. Also wenn du nur 10 Prozent von dem Geld überweisen musst, um dass du sie erleichtern möchtest, in einen Cent.
Geht das, ja? Zumindest wenn du von einem Privatgiro aus operierst und also da gibt's gibt's gute, gute Möglichkeiten.
Also das ist alles noch ein ungelöstes äh Problem. Ihr seht schon, äh es gibt tatsächlich ein paar Leute, die spenden mir irgendwie äh genau zehn Cent. Das stimmt nicht, es ist nur einer.
Von daher ach ne und jemand hat auch zwei Cent mal überwiesen davon bleibt jetzt nicht mehr viel übrig.
Also die zwei Cent sind dann minus acht.
Also kurz gesagt kleine Beträge irgendwie, ich will jetzt keine Zahl nennen so, aber,
denkt mal lieber in in ganzen Euros und ähm PayPal macht eigentlich erst so Sinn ab zehn oder zwanzig so, ne? Aber letzten Endes nimmt einfach was euch äh angemessen erscheint und dann bin ich auch schon ruhig.
Das ist ja der der Punkt ist ja auch, also äh.
Auf jeden Fall, nehmt was euch angemessen erscheint, aber wenn dieser Betrag halt ähm äh der ist dann eben potenziell besser auf ein Jahr gestückelt als aufn Monat. Äh ne?
Richtig, das wäre die andere Option, dass man halt nicht monatlich macht, ne.
Ab einem gewissen Betrag ist es dann sinnvoll, dass äh monatlich zu haben, weil es dann natürlich besser ist, weil's gleichmäßiger ist. Äh eben bei äh sehr geringen monatlichen Beträgen ist es sinnvoller und jährlich,
ähm ähm Dauerauftrag einzurichten.
So sieht's aus. Insofern äh passt das auch zu unserem äh HTTP-Status quot vierhundertzwölf heute.
Noch ganz kurz eine Sache sagen, die ist für mich wichtig, Tim, für dich nicht so, aber für mich wenn ihr mit eurer Spende Logbuch-Netzpolitik unterstützen wollt,
äh schreibt LNP mit rein, weil äh der Tim ja mehrere Podcasts macht und äh entsprechend die Spenden auch über diese Podcasts verteilt werden und das hat eben zur Folge, wenn da,
kein Podcast kommt oder wenn da LMP konkret,
genannt wird, dann wird das auch als äh zwischen uns geteilt und wenn nicht, sinnvollerweise nicht. Und ähm das äh wäre mir noch persönlich ganz wichtig. Und wenn ihr Tim gar nichts geben wollt, könnt ihr einfach mir was geben.
So würde ja niemand tun, oder? Also das kann ich mir ja gar nicht vorstellen. Ja, meinst du?
Weiß ich nicht. Du hast ja hier schon die eine oder andere ähm ähm politische Missliebigkeit geleistet.
Politische Missliebigkeit.
Ich äh ich erinnere an deine äh unkritische oder apologetische äh Meinung zum Content-Scanning bei Apple. Ja, also da äh können wir schon vorstellen, dass das äh auch.
Klar, aber man wird ja nach einzelnen Aussagen bewertet, ne? Mhm. Das ist so ein Punktesystem hier.
Ja klar.
Na ja, also schreibt ruhig LNP rein, der Linus guckt mich auch immer so komisch an, sagt was? Nur fünfzig Mark? Ich so, ja, mehr ist halt nicht. Nimm was du kriegen kannst.
Ostmark.
Aus Mark.
So genug über Geld geredet. Mit macht das äh mich macht das unrund.
Ja, ich wollte das nur an dieser Stelle mal loswerden, weil äh jetzt für die Winterkleidung und so.
Hast ja jetzt genug gebettelt.
Ja, was ich auch noch loswerden wollte ist, ich habe ähm seit langer Zeit mal wieder hm Vorträge bei YouTube hochgeladen. Ja,
ähm ich
bin ja, also ich halte relativ häufig Vorträge, aber die äh landen in der Regel dann nicht unbedingt in der Öffentlichkeit und jetzt war ich äh in einmal bei der an der LMU München
der Ludwig Maximilian Universität München in so einer Seminarreihe äh zum Thema Cyber Crime.
Und äh das war also remote und da habe ich äh weil ich ja jetzt so einen M eins Mac habe, der nicht wie ein,
Ventilator beläst, wenn man da mal eine Videoaufzeichnung macht. Äh konnte ich einfach mal mit aufzeichnen.
Und habe äh so ein paar Überlegungen zum Thema Cyber Crime äh auf YouTube hochgeladen. Und was,
was ich wirklich sehr gewundert hat über und zwar über längere Zeitraum war, ich war in Wien eingeladen äh bei einer Kunstkonferenz an der äh an der Universität für angewandte Künste
war ich schon für 2020 eingeladen, aber es ist dann aus äh naheliegenden Gründen ausgefallen, haben sie es dieses Jahr nochmal durchgeführt und haben an an der Einladung festgehalten und ich habe die immer gefragt, ey wie kommt ihr auf die Idee, dass ich was zu Kunst
sagen kann, ja, das ist ja jetzt nicht unbedingt mein ähm mein Bereich,
Aber dann habe ich einen Vortrag über die Archivierung der Gegenwart äh gehalten an der Universität für angewandte Künste und habe denen mal erzählt, was ich so für Kunst halte und äh hm
schien also hat denen glaube ich gefallen.
Teilen.
Da war jemand also jemand im Publikum hört man am Ende war äh sehr angetan. Ja.
Aha. Okay.
Genau, also die beiden äh haben immer die Shownotes verlinkt und man mir auf YouTube zu folgen ist natürlich eh äh super.
Okay. Das ist doch schön.
Statuscode, sorry, Tim, ich habe dich habe deinen Statuscode.
Ach so, ja, mein Status ist ja unser aller äh Statusquot, ne?
Startescode äh vierhundertzwölf, weil wir ja heute die Sendung vierhundertzwölf haben, heißt,
Ja, ist ein Statuscode, der, glaube ich, äh derzeit bei der Bildung der neunten Regierung täglich irgendwo aufleuchtet. Ähm wie auch schon so einige andere Status kurz, mal gucken, richtigen fetten Fehler kommen dann glaube ich erst später.
Das heißt einfach, dass wenn so eine Anfrage über das Web
äh unter Bedingungen gestellt wurde. So ein Klassiker ist so was wie äh gib mir mal die Seite, aber die darf die muss ich irgendwie im letzten zwei Wochen irgendwie geändert haben oder so etwas so und dann kann der selber sagen so ja nee.
Was habe ich hier nicht? Kriegst du nicht, ne. Das äh eigentlich so ein kleines kleines Detail.
Und sitzt findet das äh findet das Anwende.
Ja, ich denke schon. Ne, weil sie halt so äh kannst ja immer so Hedda mit mitschicken, so if unmodified Sins oder so oder wenn das irgendwie äh,
ähm oder so. Also es gibt sozusagen verschiedene if Bedingungen, die man mit so einem Request schicken kann. Ob die jetzt oft versendet werden, das ist eine andere Frage,
ja? Oder ob die Server dann in der Lage sind, die auch zuverlässig aufzulösen, ne? Ähm viel in einem HTP ist halt ist halt so,
Neunundneunzig Prozent ist halt irgendwie immer gib mal hier hast du. So, das das ist irgendwie so der der Traffic, der halt äh im Wesentlichen stattfindet. Nur,
HTP wird dann eben auch im zunehmenden Maße eben mit so APIs äh benutzt und mit irgendwie also Programme, die sich miteinander unterhalten im Prinzip. Sind
VIP Browser und Webserver ist ja letzten Endes auch zwei Programme, die sich unterhalten, aber das ist so der Klassiker. Und ähm heutzutage haben wir ja
API's äh auf allen Ebenen, wo eben Subsysteme miteinander sprechen, wenn man heute auf eine Webseite draufklickt, dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass im Hintergrund mit jedem mit jeder Website, die man abruft, irgendwie
tausende von äh Aufrufen, von anderen Diensten, von
oder Diensten dieses Unternehmens, die du auf einem anderen Server liegen äh abgefragt werden und das läuft dann halt auch letzten Endes alles über harte DP, das ist schon so ein bisschen der
Das das Universalprotokoll.
Beispiele, die ich jetzt hier so sehe, äh betreffen eher den zum Beispiel den Datei, ne? Was jetzt auf einer API-Ebene wahrscheinlich nicht so sinnvoll umsetzbar ist.
Ich find's eh komisch, dass es also if match, das if match und das heißt, du kennst den schon vorher und dann sagt er dir, ja nee, ist nicht der Hash.
Ja gib mir mal das Bild von diesem Avatar, aber ich habe hier schon noch eine Kopie äh in meinem Cash liegen und die hat diesen E Tech und wenn das immer noch der gleiche ist, dann brauchst du die Datei gar nicht erst zu übertragen. So was.
Na ja, okay, also.
Auch nicht so wichtig.
Undenkbar, ein eine, eine fundamental Säule des Internets, wie wir es kennen.
Ja, zu den lustigen äh hatte die Kurzgruppe äh in späteren Sendungen dann noch. Jetzt äh ist es reine Chronistenpflicht. So sind wir.
Äh zum Glück haben wir da nicht bei den 2hundertern oder bei den Hundertern schon angefangen.
Die Fehler sind ja immer viel interessanter. Bei Sendung 5hundert müssen wir den Betrieb einstellen.
Okay, dann hatten wir Kommentare zur letzten Sendung, relativ viele. Einmal ging's ums Impfen und Impf-Apps und so weiter. Das haben wir aber,
eh nachher noch als Thema. Da werden wir die nochmal referenzieren. Und dann gab es noch äh relativ viel äh,
Täter Opfer äh Kommentare. Äh zum Thema Drachenlord, in denen äh argumentiert wurde, so sinngemäß der ist ja selber schuld und unschuldig ist der auch nicht oder äh.
Ähm das fand ich dann doch sehr sehr unter sehr.
Befremdlich fand ich das ein bisschen.
Befremdlich, ja, also ich glaube, das habe ich ja hier oft genug gesagt. Das ist halt irgendein äh sage ich mal, in seinen Möglichkeiten recht eingeschränkter Typ, der da in irgendeinem Dorf sitzt und Internet hat und man kann entweder,
äh zum zum größten Problem der Welt stilisieren und sagen, man muss den jetzt jeden Tag belagern
und ihm dann vorwerfen, dass er irgendwann in irgendeinem Livestream beim Ausrasten mal seine Adresse gesagt hat und gesagt hat, kommt her, ich haue euch auf die Fresse und dann damit rechtfertigen, dass der jahrelang dann belagert wird.
Äh oder man kann auch einfach mal anerkennen, dass äh ja,
dass jeder Mensch, der sich mit dem auseinandersetzt, wahrscheinlich eigentlich ein anderes, wichtigeres Thema in seinem Leben haben könnte.
Sollte sogar auch. Also das ist halt einfach
In gewisser Hinsicht eine totale Belanglosigkeit. Da muss man auch nicht irgendwie kilometerlange Kommentare zu schreiben, so mit ja, aber er hat ja hier da den Fehler gemacht und hat hier den Fehler gemacht und den Fehler gemacht.
Alles sein so, aber wenn man sich damit aufhält bei Menschen so, dann dann dann kriegst du die Tür nicht mehr zu. Also wir können uns irgendwie alle unsere äh Kleinigkeiten und Fehler irgendwie äh des ganzen Lebens vorhalten
aber einfach nicht produktiv und bringt nix. So und hier ist einfach schon
viel mehr Schaden angerichtet worden, als dass diese ganze Sache jemals gerechtfertigt hat auf allen Seiten
Nicht nur bei ihm, sondern eigentlich auch bei all den Leuten, die sich diesem Thema überhaupt noch aktiv zuwenden. Macht was anderes,
interessiert euch für Dinge? Lernt irgendwas. Geht raus in die Welt, reist, tut was Gutes, aber kümmert euch nicht um.
Um so einen Menschen, der einfach ein psychisches Problem hat und irgendwie intellektuell vielleicht nicht äh auf so ein Level angekommen ist, wie wir uns das vielleicht von manchen Leuten wünschen würden.
Egal, da gibt's genug Idioten und wenn ihr irgendwie ein Problem mit äh Holocaust äh habt
Da gibt's eine sehr lange Liste von Leuten, wo ich dir das wirklich mal stören sollte, ja.
Da könntet ihr mal hinfahren. Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie lange äh da kriegt ihr auch wirklich auf die Fresse, wenn ihr dahin fahrt, ne? Nicht erst nachts nach nach fünf Jahren äh täglicher äh täglichen Mobbings. Ja, da könnt ihr mal dahin.
Auch richtig was zu erzählen. Ja und zwar nicht nur euren Freunden, sondern wahrscheinlich auch euren Arzt für mehrere Wochen.
Und dann nach eurer Krankenkasse.
Ja, da könnt ihr äh genau, äh also der euern Antifaschistische Kampf, der da haben wir ein paar Ideen, ja? Da also wie ihr da euren Helden Heldenmut unter Beweis stellen könnt, ja?
Genau. Ihr solltet mal lieber euren äh euer Chatverhalten ein bisschen kontrollieren. Weil sonst machen das nämlich andere.
Äh ja genau, äh kontrolliert mal euer Chatverhalten, da äh es ist ja wohl nicht in Ordnung, euer Chatverhalten. Wir hatten ja Patrick Breyer hier in ähm.
Der Sendung vor einiger Zeit und er hat ja.
Das muss man wirklich mal auch wieder das Engagement von Patrick Breyer hier äh nochmal hervorheben, ne. Vor diesem Scheißthema warnt er seit das irgendwie auf der Agenda weitergehendes um die E-Privacy-Richtlinieneinschränkung, ja, wo quasi gesagt wurde, ey.
Wir wir schwächen jetzt die e-Privacy-Richtlinie ab, damit Contentscanner überhaupt erlaubt werden können und im zweiten Schritt,
Werden wir dann quasi diese Contentscanner verpflichtend machen,
und das planen jetzt äh die EU-Kommission.
Und die Ratspräsidentschaft? Natürlich geht es äh wie immer äh zur Eindämmung.
Um die Eindämmung von äh Dokumentation von Kindesmissbrauch. Ja, das ist ja immer das, was uns äh äh vorgehalten wird, um Überwachungs äh Maßnahmen ähm.
Einzubringen, ja und
der Olivier Oni D, stellvertretende Generaldirektor für Inneres der EU-Kommission äh sagt natürlich, sie arbeiten jetzt an einem Gesetzvorschlag, mit dem sie versuchen wollen, alle Kommunikationsmittel in den Geltungsbereich
einzubeziehen. Alle Kommunikationsmittel heißt alle Kommunikationsmittel. Und.
Das wäre natürlich dann alle Kommunikationsmittel äh inklusive eurer Messenger und sonstigen und es soll ja hier dann ne äh die Inhalte auf dem Gerät gescannt werden,
abgeglichen werden mit ähm,
irgendwelchen Datenbanken, ähm bösartiger äh Inhalte und ne, diese technische Infrastruktur bedeutet, dass ja jedes,
jeder Text, den ihr haltet, jedes Bild, was ihr haltet, auf diese Weise äh gescannt wird und dann eben auch ähm im Fall, dass hier ein Match oder ein Verdacht entsteht, ähm,
sofortige Meldung passiert. Ja ähm.
Das ist der das, was wir an in den ganz großen Cloud Inhalten auch schon sehen, ja? Apple äh hat ja ähnliche Pläne.
Vorangebracht und hier in dieser Diskussion, die ich ja gerade schon mit Tim auch referenziert habe, ist es ja so, dass Apple letztendlich versucht hat, das so,
technisch sauber und Privatsphäre nicht verletzt sind wie möglich irgendwie zu bauen, ja und dass es natürlich damals die Diskussion gab, ist das jetzt hier ein Vorstoß von Apple eines scheiß Technologie zu bauen oder ist es ein Vorstoß von Apple.
Die Pflicht,
Eine Scheiß-Technologie zu bauen, möglichst ihr vorauszukommen, indem er diese scheiß Technologie so akzeptabel wie möglich noch baut.
Das sind ja die beiden äh Seiten der Medaille und Patrick Breyer ist eben äh jemand, der sinnvollerweise hier mal äh anbringt,
dass es eine sehr schlechte Idee ist,
verpflichtend zu machen, denn wenn das jedes Kommunikationsmittel betrifft, ja, ich meine, du kannst dir vorstellen, egal wie klein hinterm Komma der Alpha- und Beta-Fehler ist,
ist er halt enorm, ja? Und ähm gleichzeitig würde ich auf jeden Fall die These vertreten, ganz klar.
Dass ähm ein absolut geringster Prozentsatz,
von regulärer Kommunikation, was weiß ich über SMS, iMate, Message oder was. In diesen, in diese Art des illegalen Bereiches geht.
Die Leute wären bekloppt das zu tun. Und sie werden erst recht bekloppt, das zu tun, wenn sie,
wissen, dass es eine solche Technologie gibt.
Ja? Dann setzen die sich irgendwie ein Tor Hidden Service auf, äh machen Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte äh Bildertausch und niemand von denen wird dadurch ähm,
an der Ausübung äh dieser illegalen Tätigkeiten gehindert werden. Das Einzige, was bei Massenüberwachungssystem bleibt, ist das diejenigen, die,
nichts zu verbergen haben,
Massenüberwachung ein Heimfallen, während diejenigen, die etwas zu verbergen haben, sich ohne Probleme der Technologien ermächtigen,
as zu tun.
Und die Leute, die um nichts zu verbergen haben, werden dann feststellen, dass sie doch eigentlich eine ganze Menge zu verbergen haben.
Ja
Und das könnte dann unter Umständen nicht ganz so gut gelaufen sein für sie.
Es gab jetzt auch kürzlich ein Paper veröffentlicht am 14. Oktober,
Leute mitgeschrieben wie Ross Anderson ja äh,
äh Kamela von ja, das also wirklich so das who is who der äh Kryptographie Witfi, ja, so einmal einmal alle, das ist der Diffi aus Tiffy Helmen, ja? Ähm,
die ähm ein ein relativ langes Paper geschrieben haben. The risk of client Zeit Scanning. Ja und klein Zeit Scanning ist letztendlich das, was hier mit diesem ähm,
mit dieser Chatkontrolle angeleiert werden soll und das ist ein,
großes Problem und die Argumentation dagegen kommen ja hier spezifisch von den äh Kryptografen, die äh und Kryptografinnen, die.
Ja, sagen wir mal, die Power von Kryptografie kennen, ja und wissen, was kannst du damit machen, was geht, was geht nicht? Kryptographie ist ja eine der Technologien, die massiv,
über ähm überschätzt ist,
Teilweise unterschätzt ist, ne? Also wenn du an irgendetwas dran schreibst, ist verschlüsselt, sagen die Leute einer so, ah geil, dann kann nichts mehr passieren, das ist jetzt sicher, ja, ohne zu wissen, wieso. Gleichzeitig, wenn du sagst, etwas ist verschlüsselt, wir kommen da nicht dran, sonst kann man das nicht irgendwie knacken,
und die hier haben sich eben wirklich mal äh das der Kryptographie zusammengetan und haben gesagt, okay ähm.
Was ist äh äh was was wird hier gebaut? Und sie kommen zu dem Schluss, wenn Content äh,
konnte äh man sorry wie heißt das nochmal? CSS ich jetzt gerade gesagt.
Also wenn dieses Content-Scanning in der Breite ausgerollt wird, ist der einzige Schutz im Gesetz.
Und das ist sehr schlecht. Ja und das sagen diejenige, die äh diejenigen, die halt,
IT Security machen, ja? Die die Foundations von IT Security sagen, also das kann man nicht machen,
und das ist eine schlechte Idee. Sie analysieren den Vorschlag von Apple und sagen, das kann einfach nicht,
sicher umgesetzt werden vom von der Architektur her.
Und ich denke, dass es eine sehr, sehr wichtige Publikation, die natürlich von allen wieder ignoriert werden wird, äh
ähm sie setzen sich mit allen Content-Scanning Methoden auseinander, ne, Machine Learning, Percepuil-Hashing, das ist also dieses Foto DNA
scannen äh auch für den Serverseite, scannen auf der Client Seite, ja und erklären bei allem, warum das halt ein Problem ist.
Und welche äh ähm
Bedrohung damit einhergehen, nämlich das autorisierte Stellen, das Missbrauchen
unautorisierte Stellen das missbrauchen, ja, dass es äh lokale Angriffe äh gibt auf diese Systeme und ähm,
wo quasi gegen Security Engineering Best Practices verstoßen wird, wenn man so etwas baut und äh es ist halt wirklich einmal ein vernichtendes Urteil von denjenigen, die ja letztendlich,
die die Grundsteine der IT-Sicherheit verstanden haben und natürlich auch der Privatsphäre. Ähm,
und damit ähm sich ja, also halt in dem in dem Bereich der Fehler äh.
Solcher Systeme natürlich auch auskennen und vor allem sie nicht überschätzen, weil wenn jetzt jemand sagt, also ne, wenn jemand sagt, pass auf, wenn da irgendwie so eine,
Dokumentation aufm Handy kommt, geht eine Meldung ein, super, ja, das klingt ja sehr fein, aber es ist eben so
du jetzt da null Komma null ein Prozent Fehler drin hast, zerstörst du halt irgendwelche äh Leben. Du du überwachst irgendwie Journalistinnen und Journalisten mit?
Und du verhinderst halt äh ne, du jeder Mensch weiß, okay, mein Handy,
wenn der Tier sich irgendwie mit mit meinen Kommunikationsinhalten nicht äh zufrieden ist und es soll ja nicht nur um Bilder gehen, sondern die wollen ja auch äh quasi KI-Analysen auf die Inhalte machen.
Um irgendwie zu sagen, hör mal, da macht der Tim sich aber gerade an eine äh an ein kleines Kind dran. Der hat doch gesagt, ich liebe dich oder ich habe dich lieb. Ja?
Und äh ach so, das war die Tochter, ne, weißt du so ähm das ist eine sehr, sehr schlechte Idee und ähm ich denke tatsächlich, dass äh das sehr Under reportet ist im Moment noch und dass wir.
Da dem Patrick Breyer äh,
alle Unterstützung zukommen lassen müssen und dass hier eine äh sehr klare äh ein sehr klarer Widerstand äh auf EU-Ebene in Anführungszeichen international oder Euronational,
mit mit aller Schärfe gegen vorgegangen werden muss, weil das ist also das wäre wirklich so ein Ding, wo ich echt anfangen würde.
Ähm ja in den Untergrund zu gehen, ne. Also dann muss ich mir dann brauche ich meine selbstgebastelten Android-Telefone, weil das werde ich nicht akzeptieren.
Jetzt die Frage, äh inwiefern hier ein politischer Widerstand äh am besten noch organisiert werden kann oder inwiefern ähm wir überhaupt auch nur von unserer Bundesregierung äh auf Unterstützung hoffen können. Jetzt haben wir ja.
Von denen kannst du nicht auf äh Unterstützung hoffen, dass er geht ja auf die zurück.
Aber wir haben ja jetzt eine Neue. Also vermutlich bald.
Ach so. Ach so, der Tim hat immer noch nicht verstanden, wie das mit den Wahlen ist.
Ja gut, aber ist ja ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man äh.
Überhaupt gar keine Kursänderung erwarten kann. Ja, also sicherlich werden nicht alle glücklich werden, das ist ja immer so, äh gar keine Frage, aber ähm,
die FDP hat da einen Ruf zu verlieren, was so ihren Freiheitsbegriff äh betrifft, ne, im Netz und hat uns irgendwie jetzt jahrelang erzählt, mit ihnen wird alles besser und ähm die Grünen haben sich da auch äh
positioniert, weil der SPD braucht man da, glaube ich, jetzt äh nicht über Prinzipien zu reden.
Das ist sicherlich jetzt auch ähm die Gelegenheit, noch vor äh Regierungsbildung hier äh entsprechenden Einfluss zu nehmen.
Also wenn du ähm es geht ja oft von der Kommission aus, wenn du da wenn du da jemanden mit deutscher Sprache äh erreichen möchtest,
wendest du dich als allererstes einfach an Ursula von der Leyen, ja? Telefonnummer plus zweiunddreißig zwei zwei neun fünf sechs null sieben null.
Viel Spaß ja? Also bei der die Frau war ja schon immer ein rationalen Argumenten zugänglich. Das dürfte also ein Leichtes sein.
Ja, aber auch die äh Kommission macht ja nichts im luftleeren äh Raum. Da gibt's immer noch das Parlament und wenn sich das Parlament dagegen ausspricht.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt schon den Eindruck, dass die wird im Luft rein. Also okay, das ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema, das ist ein wichtiges Thema und äh wir werden, denke ich, sicherlich den Patrick dazu nochmal zeitnah einladen.
Äh um dafür zu sorgen, dass wir das äh angehen können, dass wir das verhindern können. Das ist sehr wichtig
scheint mir das wichtigste Thema zu sein der nächsten Zeit. So, wir haben gesagt, wir reden noch ein bisschen über Corona.
Das ist auch wichtig. Äh äh ich finde kaum jemand redet noch darüber. Muss man auch einfach drüber reden. Das Thema ist schon fast raus aus dem News Circle.
Corona-Apps, ja?
Mit Corona-Apps. Ich relativ einfach, ja? Brauchen wir auch gar nicht weiter drüber einzugehen, ähm ein,
äh ein Gerichtsverfahren in Rostock, also für für den äh für Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Am Oberlandesgericht Rostock hat den Kauf der Luca-App für rechtswidrig und unwirksam erklärt, weil,
die Ausschreibung nicht äh und die Vergabe nicht ordnungsgemäß stattgefunden hat,
ja? Ähm das äh die äh das Land hat quasi argumentiert, ja nee, das war aber hier dringlich und das Gericht hat halt argumentiert, na ja
von mir aus war das dringlich, eine äh Corona App zu beschaffen, aber kannst nicht einfach den den Webweb ausschließen, nur weil Smudo,
im Fernsehen saß und gesagt hat, ich habe das Geilste seit geschnitten Brot. Ja,
Man muss natürlich also man muss nochmal betonen dazu sagen ja dass es überhaupt zu dieser Luka-App kam, liegt am Versagen von Jens Spahn, weil wir eine Corona-Warn-App,
hatten oder auch immer noch haben und das Gesundheitsministerium verzögert hat darin einen Location Check-in einzubauen. Wissentlich und schuldhaft und fahrlässig verzögert hat. Und dann.
Damit quasi eine Lücke für die äh für die Luca-App geschaffen hat, weil ein ähm eine Funktionalität, die,
ja vorgeschrieben war oder angefordert war. Aus der eigenen Verordnung der Bundesregierung nicht abgedeckt hat. Ja, also sie haben gesagt, ja müssen sie Kontaktnachverfolgung machen in der Gastronomie. Äh und zwar mit einer äh am besten mit einer App.
Eine App? Nee, was für eine App? Ja und dann haben sie natürlich, sie haben sich quasi, ne, rechte Hand, linke Hand, keine Ahnung und haben damit,
es ermöglicht, dass diese Covid-Glücksritter,
da mit einer wirklich einer App in einer Qualität, die du es ist sehr lächerlich. Wir verfolgen das ja schon gar nicht mehr. Wie oft da es wieder zu Problemen kommt, dann melden die wieder Tage lang nicht.
Ja? Ähm und absolute Katastrophe und wie gesagt, wir haben das damals als CCC, wir haben ja die Bundesnotbremse äh für,
die Luca-App gefordert.
Ähm und wir haben damals gesagt, das sollte sich doch bitte mal diese Vergabe Praktik sollte sich bitte mal der äh Bundesrechnungshof oder die Landesrechnungshofe anschauen. Ja, letztendlich haben dann hier die,
die Konkurrentinnen dafür gesorgt, dass die zumindest in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, es waren ja die ersten, damit ist der Stein ja ins Rollen gekommen, äh zumindest in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern,
der Kauf äh oder diese Vergabe eben als rechtswidrig. Ähm.
Abgeurteilt und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das nicht das einzige Land bleiben wird, denn was die damals verkauft haben, wissen wir ja außerdem, war ja noch gar nicht fertig.
Ja, also darf man darf ja nochmal dran erinnern, die sind ja bis heute nicht fertig mit dieser App,
Ja? Also zentrale Funktionalitäten, die haben hier gesagt, ja wir haben ja aber hier die die Sormas Anbindung, Pustekuchen, das wäre irgendein CSV-Export,
wo wo hier Markus dann am Ende noch eine eine äh Injection in Excel gebastelt hat, ja? Also totale,
Also eine eine wirklich äh eine Start-up-Mentalität zu sagen, wir haben hier eine Idee, kauf das mal,
Wenn ihr wenn ihr das kauft, dann fangen wir an Leute zu heuern. Haben wir ja hier auch besprochen die Mails von diesem HPI Institutsdirektor, der dann irgendwie schon bevor,
das Ding gekauft wurde der Studierendenschaft geschrieben hat, ey das wird bald gekauft, die suchen jetzt Leute, die das programmieren, ja? Ich meine,
Das ist alles so also das ist es ist einfach nur ein Skandal und ähm ich bin froh, dass der jetzt endlich,
aufgeräumt wird, ja? Ähm Thomas D weißt inzwischen Vorwürfe zurück, sie es wäre ihn dabei nur um die Kohle gegangen,
So, die merken jetzt auch, an wen sie da geraten sind, ja und gleichzeitig ähm.
Äh sei an dieser Stelle mal angemerkt, ich habe ja mit Journalisten Kontakt, ja und wer irgendwie wenn du äh negative Berichterstattung über die Luka-App machst, ja, dann kriegst du Post von Anwälten, dann mahnen die ab,
Die die haben dir keine Probleme irgendwelche äh Abmahnungen sogar gegen öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk zu schreiben. Wenn du wenn du sagst, diese App äh hat dieses oder jenes, ja?
Hast du das auch bekommen?
Das können Sie ja mal versuchen. Also das das Problem ist ja, dass Sie wissen, dass ich das sehr gut verargumentieren kann, warum das alles nicht in Ordnung ist. Aber klar, die werden also äh ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass hier so,
so Leute wie Patrick Hennig natürlich auch diese Sendung hören und auf jeden Fall lauern sie. Ja und haben irgendwelche haben halt eine äh Anwaltskanzlei,
interessantem Ruf. Äh damit beauftragt äh hier so dagegen vorzugehen, ja. Ähm.
Es ist halt wirklich ich kann nur sagen, es ist halt eine äh also es ist wirklich ein sehr peinliches Ding und klar, es werden an anderer Stelle wird sehr viel mehr Geld ähm verballert, ne? Also,
die App ist ja relativ gut bewertet im im Play Store, weißt du wieso?
Weil die beim wenn du da jetzt irgendwie, du du checkst in eine Location ein, ne? Und bei beim Checkout sagen sie, ey willst du nicht eine Bewertung hinterlassen? Und dieser Playstore ist voll mit Bewertungen,
für die Restaurants.
Weil die Leute nicht gecheckt haben, was sie da jetzt eigentlich gerade bewerten.
Hä? Super leckeres äh Vanilleeis.
Service sehr freundlich.
Ja wirklich.
So, das ist natürlich auch ähm sagen wir mal, das kann kann auch ein Versehen sein.
Klar. Könnte vielleicht auch ein Versehen sein, ist äh vorstellbar.
Und gleichzeitig, ne, ich meine dann irgendwie so bei so einer App von beliebt zu sprechen, wenn du es schaffst, ja, dass dein privatwirtschaftliches Trackingprodukt in Landesverordnungen vorgeschrieben ist. Dann kannst du ja nicht mehr sagen, ey voll geil unsere App
Alle haben
ja? Also das ist ja wirklich, ich meine, das ist, na ja. Äh wie gesagt, wir haben größere Probleme in diesem Land und es wäre einfach nur schön, wenn man äh da jetzt mal den äh Geldhahn zudrehen könnte. Die Corona-Warn-App.
Scannt ja jetzt auch äh Luca QR Codes. Es war ja zum Anfang von Luca schon äh relativ zeitnah versprochen worden. Ähm,
Die Corona-Warn-App hat ja ähm auch eine Check-in-Funktion, die aber eben dezentral und vor allem,
direkt und schneller ist. Du erhältst die Warnung direkt und nicht durch irgendeine Sachbearbeiterin, die dann irgendwie im Gesundheitsamt gucken muss.
Und anonym.
Und anonym hatten wir übrigens hier kürzlich, ne? Freund und ich,
haben haben eine rote Warnung gehabt nach einem Gastronom Gastronomiebesuch, aber ist ein anderes Thema, komme ich gleich nochmal zu.
Und jetzt hat die äh CWA quasi gesagt, okay, wir scannen die Luca QR Codes und interpretieren die in unserem Sinne.
Ja, also die der luca-QR-Code ist ja, was weiß ich, hat die Location und so was fest drin genannt, ja? Und jetzt gehen die einfach hin, nehmen den und interpretieren den wie ein corona-Warnapp.
Code,
ja? Dummerweise haben die äh äh Lucavögel aber äh ihre QR-Codes nicht gemäß der eigenen Spezifikation immer umgesetzt, sodass erst äh QR-
mit der äh Corona-Warn-App funktioniert. Sicherlich auch ein bedauerliches Versehen
dass hier die Kompatibilität von Seiten Luka kaputt gemacht wurde, ne? Luca kann nicht mit Corona-Warn-App äh QR-Codes umgehen.
Ähm ähm also ja äh,
geile Sache, ja? Das ist der Gebug ist irgendwie, dass dann da äh Andy Feind steht, weil die eben in ihr eigenes Feld nix reinschreiben.
Na ja, übrigens äh äh gibt's jetzt auch eine Rüge vom Bund der Steuerzahler für die Luka App?
Ja, also äh geht jetzt langsam los. Ich frage mich, wer davor die ganze Zeit gewarnt hat. Ich glaube, bei der CCC, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher und wir. Aber okay,
Es gibt natürlich dann grundsätzlich noch die Frage, also die die ich hier auch nochmal mit dir diskutieren wollte,
Kontaktnachverfolgung. Also hat das gerade überhaupt noch also wir müssen ja mal überlegen, hat das irgendwie was gebracht?
Und ich ich würde inzwischen.
Ich muss noch eine Sache vorher erzählen. So. Ich habe ja jetzt gesagt, rote Warnung in der Corona-Warn-App, ne? Jetzt äh.
Gibt es auch auf Netz für Tick Ork, die haben wir bis jetzt auch mal grade behandelt, ja?
Wenn du da eine rote Warnung hast und gehst zum Arzt oder so, dann wissen die in der Regel nicht, dass das eine ähm dass du damit jetzt eigentlich einen PCR-Test bekommen solltest.
So, da steht nicht in der äh in der in der App drin, ja und entsprechend wissen das halt Leute nicht. Das heißt, du kriegst irgendwie eine ähm eine rote Warnung.
Äh und wenn es dich irgendwohin, also offiziell heißt es, wer eine rote Warnung in der CBA hat, hat einen Anspruch auf einen PCR-Test im öffentlichen Testzentrum kostenlos und so weiter, ja? Äh Coronatestverordnung,
Steht das aber so nicht ganz drin,
Jens Spahn hat das aber vor allem ja schon angekündigt und die FAQ auf der Seite des Gesundheitsministeriums äh stellen, dass so ein bisschen,
ähm äh schränken diesen Anspruch ein bisschen, ja? Und jetzt äh weiß halt niemand.
Äh was was genau passiert. Ja und manche Leute rufen halt irgendwie eins, eins, sechs, eins, eins, sieben ab und kriegen ähm
Dann zum Beispiel von der am von der äh kostenärztlichen Bundesvereinigung gesagt, ja sie sind ja doppelt geimpft, deswegen dann ist der PCR-Test nicht kostenlos. Ja herzlichen Dank, da bist du geimpft, ja?
Bist also nicht einer von den Volldeppen sagst, ich würde gerne jetzt so zur Sicherheit noch ein PCR-Test machen, dann sagen die als Dankeschön, ne dich testen wir jetzt nicht,
Bei dir riskieren wir einen Durchbruch. Also das ist auch wirklich, na ja. Äh wer mitdenkt, äh wird bestraft, äh ist hier so eine.
Überschrift. Die Hotlines weisen nicht darauf hin. Also das ist auch natürlich wieder, ne, da siehst du halt, dass das nicht äh ähm,
nicht sinnvoll umgesetzt wird. Ja und vor dem Hintergrund jetzt die Frage, was halten wir denn eigentlich jetzt von diesem Contacttracing?
Also zunächst einmal ähm und das ist jetzt natürlich nur eine lokale Information, es gibt jetzt hier in Berlin so äh Testzentren, die von den Landesämtern betrieben werden. Da kann man sehr wohl hingehen und kriegt auch
Test mit einer roten Corona-Warn-App. So, also das ist auch nicht so, dass das jetzt überall äh automatisch ein Problem ist, aber gerade so bei Ärzten
et cetera. Da ist auch einfach die Kommunikation, glaube ich, äh nicht ausreichend erfolgt, dass sie das so wissen oder sich sicher sein können oder keine Ahnung. Vielleicht,
konkrete Erfahrungen dahingehend gesammelt haben, dass sie das mal angenommen haben,
es ihnen dann hintenrum sozusagen nicht mehr erstattet wurde oder so, ne? Also auch so was kann man jetzt nicht ganz ausschließen. Grundsätzlich ist es natürlich so mit dieser Kontaktverfolgung, das ist halt auch so ein bisschen ähm.
In einem bestimmten Scale, ist das halt einfach äh gar nicht mehr durchführbar. Kontaktverfolgung ist die klassische Bekämpfung von Infektionskrankheiten,
also vor ein paar Jahren war das so, man hat einen Masernausbruch und dann,
das Gesundheitsamt und telefoniert dem hinterher. Dann wurde das eben zu so einem großen aufgeblasen, dass das jetzt hier äh unsere Chance ist, äh alles in den Griff zu bekommen.
Bis zu einer bestimmten Inzidenz, die dann natürlich schnell gerissen wurde. Die Pandemie hat sich immer weiter ausgebreitet und zu den Hochphasen, die wir jetzt auch wieder haben, ist vollkommen klar, dass dem manuell überhaupt gar nicht beizukommen.
Ist und von daher, denke ich, hat die Kontaktverfolgung als solche durch die Gesundheitsämter sicherlich hier und da Ergebnisse erzielt
so, aber war dann auch nicht mehr in der Lage, diese Pandemie als solche in den Griff zu bekommen. Da waren dann halt die anderen Maßnahmen sehr viel effizienter. Vor allem natürlich der Lockdown.
Masken tragen, all diese ganzen Sachen, also die nichtmedizinischen Interventionen, die äh hier ähm zum Tragen kamen, natürlich auch das Absagen von vielen äh Events, privaten Kontakten et cetera, das haben wir ja nur auch
alles ausreichend durchgemacht und jetzt hatten wir eben halt wieder so einen Sommer der Entspannung und dann ist es halt einfach so, dass bei allen natürlich bei uns auch, mir auch, ja, äh innerlich dieser Wunsch sich breit macht, na ja.
Vorbei. Ich habe jetzt auch keinen Bock mehr.
Egal so und dann natürlich äh in dieser Situation, wo man auch noch geimpft ist, natürlich so eine gewisse Grundsicherheit auch wieder äh hergestellt hat. Also vielleicht nicht
tatsächlich wirklich, sondern eben so jetzt habe ich aber auch was dagegen getan. Ich will jetzt, dass es vorbei ist. Äh mehr kann ich sowieso grad nicht dagegen tun. Ähm weil natürlich dieser Dauerzustand der Belagerung auch irgendwo mental eine ganze Menge Schäden
macht. Im Prinzip ist die Coronawanne, also gibt zwei, glaube ich, zwei Seiten, von denen man das bewerten kann, ne? Das eine ist natürlich,
Was man äh diesen ganzen Systematiken vorwerfen kann, mit so einer Technikgläubigkeit,
Kommt man daher und sagt, ja wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie ein tolles Tool. Wir haben die Smartphones und damit können wir das irgendwie in den Griff kriegen. Das geht natürlich schon ein bisschen davon aus
alle haben was verstanden, alle benutzen das, alle machen das und alle halten sich dann auch an diese Warnungen. Dazu brauchst du aber Erfahrung.
Ne? So was so was muss über Erfahrung, über positive Erfahrungen verstärkt werden. Am Anfang gibt's da eine große Bereitschaft, dann probiert man das aus, aber dann will man eben auch
positive Rückmeldung haben. Und ich denke, dass
an der Stelle jetzt viel gelernt wurde, was alles auch irgendwie falsch gemacht wurde, dass falsche Dinge angezeigt wurden, die Sprache zu kompliziert ist, äh Informationen einfach fehlten. Also das ist ja auch für alle das erste Mal. Nichtsdestotrotz denke ich,
äh die CBA schon auch Fälle verhindert. Ja.
Äh äh spezifisch, also äh äh wenn ich da ganz kurz einhaken darf, ja, ähm ich würde jetzt mal zusammenfassen, was du gerade gesagt hast, ist vor allem also Kontaktnachverfolgung ist besonders,
sinnvoll, solange äh eigentlich im Prinzip bei Niedrig-Inzidenzen.
Und zweitens, das ist das andere, was wir auch immer gesagt haben.
Dass das Wichtigste bei Kontaktnachverfolgung ist, dass sie schnell funktioniert und deswegen ist die der der äh der,
das größte Moment der Effizienzsteigerung natürlich eine automatische Alarmierung, wie sie die Corona-Warn-App umgesetzt hat.
Ja? Geschwindigkeit, Geschwindigkeit, Geschwindigkeit ist das Einzige, was an diesem Prozess sinnvoll zu optimieren ist, ja? Und dann,
und dass ja der andere Punkt, den du gerade auch ansprichst, Konsequenzen, ja, es muss Konsequenzen geben,
es muss was passieren. Äh ähm da äh nämlich die Unterbrechung von Infektionsketten.
Ja? Und wenn du dann wenn die Leute dann da stehen und sagen, äh ich habe hier eine Warnung, aber jetzt kriege ich keinen PCR-Test oder sonst was. Ähm da hat er dann auch einfach keiner Bock drauf. Ja? Natürlich kommen dann noch viele,
andere Probleme hinzu, aber ich würde dir zustimmen, auf jeden Fall hat die Corona-Warnapp geholfen, Infektionen zu verhindern,
gleichzeitig, das haben wir auch, das das muss ja auch jedes Mal nochmal dazu erklären, du kannst die verhinderten Infektionen nur schätzen, also,
modellieren, äh rechnen, wie viele normalerweise Leute angesteckt haben und Leute, die früher in Quarantäne gehen nicht
ja? Dadurch kannst du dann sagen, okay so und so viel wurde wahrscheinlich verhindert, aber natürlich kannst du nicht die äh die genaue Zahl ähm bestimmen. Und was mich ehrlich gesagt,
so ärgert, ist, dass.
Es war für alle ein Experiment ja und es ist immer noch eines, auch die Luka-App ist ein Experiment. Aber nach einem sehr guten Start wurde halt die Corona-Warn-App so fürchterlich stiefmütterlich,
behandelt, sodass man an der natürlich auch noch eine ganze Menge äh meckern muss leider heutzutage, ne?
Ja, also das war, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen das Kernproblem. Wenn man noch mal zurückblättert, wie das mit der Corona-Warn-App passiert ist, das ist ja eigentlich ist es ja ein totaler Glücksfall gewesen.
Normalerweise weiß halt diese Regierung eigentlich nicht, was sie tut. Und äh insbesondere im Digitalen nicht, das äh haben wir ja nun schon
oft genug hier ausgebreitet und das wäre ja in dem Moment auch fast wieder so gewesen. Diese diese dieser dieser Fiebertraum einer zentralen, eines zentralen Trackings aller Bewegungen, ja, wenn man sich schon anschaut, wie die Zurückhaltung bei der durchaus gelungenen Corona-Warn-App letzten Endes war.
Wahrscheinlich auch wegen dieser ganzen ursprünglichen Diskussion. Äh niemals hätte ein anderes System, was dann unter permanenten Kritikdauerfeuer
äh in irgendeiner Form einen Erfolg machen können. Aber dann war's halt irgendwie eher so ein politischer Unfall, dass äh in dieser ganzen Debatte
Die Regierung halt jetzt in irgendeiner Form zu einer Lösung kommen wollte und auch so ein bisschen ihre lange Liste von Themen, die jetzt ganz dringend bearbeitet werden muss, runterkürzen muss, dass sie einfach gesagt haben, scheiß drauf auf diese Diskussion haben wir jetzt grade mal keinen Bock, jetzt machen wir das halt mal so wie der CCC das gesagt hat
und natürlich viele andere auch. Und dann ist eben in dem Moment mal wirklich eine Konstellation entstanden, wo ich sagen würde, ja genau so brauchen wir das öfter.
Ja, Open Source Entwicklung, kompetente Leute, die sich daran gesetzt haben, ausreichend Ressourcen.
Äh Verhältnismäßig klaren Ziel, was eben vor allem Dank der Initiative von Apple und Google, die
quasi von vornherein so einen technischen Rahmen gesetzt haben, so nach dem Motto, ja, könnt ihr haben, meinetwegen, aber nur bitte in genau diesem Modell und das machen wir jetzt und was anderes kriegt ihr eh nicht, ja? Das äh äh dass dann eben durchaus ein Prozess gestartet wurde, der sinnvoll war. Bloß dann kam halt sofort wieder diese
schnelle politische Ermüdung, nachdem das Ding dann veröffentlicht war, dachte sich so, ja wieso, jetzt haben wir ja die App jetzt jetzt
kümmern wir uns wieder um was anderes kümmern und dass dann eben nicht genug Energie reingesteckt wurde, das Ding auch konsequent
weiterzudenken und das ist natürlich dann auch so der Unfall mit der Luka-App gewesen, weil das eben von Anfang an eine Funktionalität war, die man sehr wohl da hätte einfach auch reindenken
müssen, wie viele andere Sachen auch. Man hatte im Prinzip die Gelegenheit, so einen One-Stop-Shop zu machen für Corona. Aber es hat Monate gedauert, bis da einfach mal nur Inzidenzen angezeigt wurden. Es hat,
ewig gedauert.
In irgendeiner Form die aktuelle Lage darüber kommuniziert wurde und wir hatten ja auch diese ganze Diskussion hier mit diesen anderen Warnapps äh von denen wir ja irgendwie Tausende haben, Nina und Catwarn und hast nicht gesehen. Ja
wenn irgendwie was Schlimmes ist. Nur in diesem einen Fall war es ja durchaus sinnvoll
mal zu bündeln, wurde dann aber bloß nicht gebündelt und dann war's halt Luca App hier und tausend andere App-Ideen dort und natürlich geht dann äh der Fokus in der Öffentlichkeit auch einfach weg,
Ich finde, dass was jetzt am Ende bei rausgekommen ist, nachdem dann eben,
auch wieder mehr Konzentration auf die Weiterentwicklung gelegt wurde und sehr viel sinnvolle Features äh nachgerüstet wurden, sobald ich das beurteilen kann auch äh in,
brauchbare Art und Weise, also da kam die Zertifikate, das Überprüfen ist jetzt auch noch mit drin et cetera. Da gibt's im Detail äh noch viel äh äh zu meckern, aber grundsätzlich war der war der Schritt meiner Meinung nach sehr richtig.
Äh nur dass eben dieser ganze Prozess, jetzt komme ich auch wieder zurück auf diese Kontaktverfolgung.
Äh dieses wie bekämpfen wir denn jetzt wirklich das Infektionsgeschehen damit, irgendwie nie so richtig zu Ende gedacht wurde, vor allem, weil die Psychologie der Leute, glaube ich, nicht ausreichend berücksichtigt wurde? Beispiel rote Warnung. Jetzt hat man eine rote Warnung,
Am Anfang war's ja auch schwierig, so wann ist eine Warnung wirklich kritisch und wann nicht und so, aber jetzt hat man so eine rote Warnung. Also du hast dich äh nennenswerte Zeitraum über unter Leuten aufgehalten von den,
mindestens eine Person später jetzt nachweislich einen positiven PCR-Test hatte. Das ist ja im Prinzip das, was die rote Warnung sagt. So, sei mal ein bisschen vorsichtig und teste dich am besten.
Jetzt kriege ich das als Rückmeldung und dann steht da drauf, das war an dem Datum. So und ich hatte das auch mal.
Ich wusste an dem Tag bin ich irgendwie den ganzen Tag im Zug gesessen, dann war ich an einer Veranstaltung,
saß ich nochmal zwei Stunden im Zug. Ich hatte aber keinerlei Informationen darüber,
wann diese rote Warnung jetzt quasi war, obwohl das Telefon das wahr ist und mir die App das auch sagen könnte.
Aber ich wusste nicht, was jetzt in deinem ersten Zug war es auf dieser Veranstaltung, war's danach. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, ja ist ja egal, du sollst sie ja nur testen lassen und so weiter. Äh das ist jetzt erstmal das Wichtige. Klar ist, dass das eigentlich das Wichtige. Aber es macht einen Unterschied.
Mir genau gesagt wird so, hier, ich habe ein konkretes Bedrohungsszenario äh äh festgestellt und zwar jetzt sagen wir mal, es wäre diese Veranstaltung gewesen,
kriege ich ja auch ein spezifischeres Gefühl dafür ähm ob,
Wie ich mich künftig auch bei solchen Veranstaltungen verhalte, weil jetzt ist es irgendwie diffus. Klar, wenn ich den ganzen Tag nur an einem Ort rumgehangen habe,
In dem Fall äh macht's vielleicht keinen Unterschied. Aber das sind so so Kleinigkeiten, wo glaube ich hier noch mehr dran gearbeitet werden muss und äh das ist auch durchaus noch möglich, aber dazu muss es,
eingebaut sein.
Aber das sollte ja, das sollte ja dann eigentlich mit dem Location Check-In, der ja dann auch sehr verspätet kam, äh Einzug finden.
Genau, das ist natürlich dieser explizite Vorgang, aber der muss natürlich dann auch immer erstmal von den Leuten gemacht werden. Man muss irgendwie das Telefon in die Hand nehmen, man muss die App starten, man muss es gerne aufmachen, man muss den QR-Code finden, dann muss es funktionieren. Und ähm das machen zwar viele auch
So und das ist auch eine durchaus sinnvolle Funktionalität, aber diese Automatikfunktion ist natürlich auch Gold wert.
Bevor wir jetzt in die Detaildiskussion dieser App gehen, die ich ja durchaus auch teile, ja, würde ich würde ich eigentlich mal nochmal was ganz anderes diagnostizieren.
Wenn du als äh Bürgerin, ja, den den Regierungsvorgaben und Empfehlungen für Corona-Apps folgst. Ja? Dann hast du auf deinem Telefon die Corona-Warn-App,
die Funktionsüberschneidungen hat oder sinnvolle Anwendungsüberschneidungen hat, mit der Luka-App.
Die sinnvolle Funktionsüberschneidung hat mit der App und der Koffpass-Check-App. Das heißt, wir haben vier.
Corona-Apps, die wir die wir zumindest zu bestimmten Zeitpunkten immer sinnvollerweise installieren sollten mussten konnten. Ja, also Koffpass-Check äh ne, Corona-Warn-App kann keine äh Impfzertifikate von anderen scannen und so weiter und so fort.
Sie mittlerweile auch, aber kam halt erst später.
Genau und äh das genau der Punkt. Hier fehlt sehr offensichtlich,
eine Gesamtstrategie. Die haben sich immer einfach den neusten Shit von irgendwelchen dahergelaufenen äh Sales Druiden andrehen lassen. Ob die Smoodo hießen oder von IBM kamen?
Und das ist das das ist das Erbe von äh unserem äh guten Freund Jens Spahn. Ja, der äh äh Gesundheitsminister äh dieses Landes ist, dass die nicht,
einmal in in Anbetracht einer Pandemie, wo du wenigstens mal wirklich,
eine neue Situation hast, ja? Normalerweise kriegen die den ganzen Shit nicht digitalisiert wegen äh Blowed, Legacy und so weiter, ja, weil sie sagen, das haben wir ja schon seit 30 Jahren so gemacht, das können wir jetzt nicht einfach modernisieren,
Ähm bei der Kontaktverfolgung hatten sie eine Open Source Software, die selber von der deutschen Bundesregierung finanziert wurde,
haben die nicht äh nicht nicht sinnvoll eingesetzt und nicht für für deren Einsatz gesorgt und haben sich dann von letztendlich die ganze Zeit irgendwelchen windigen Vögeln äh irgendeinen Quatsch andrehen lassen, bis hin zu fünf Blockchains.
Da sind ich meine, da finde ich das natürlich ähm äh du hast ja richtig, äh du hast ja Recht, wenn du jetzt ähm sagen wir mal die die Probleme.
Ähm.
Corona-Warn-App in den Usability-Abläufen und so weiter äh detailliert äh diskutierst, ja? Aber das ist ja irgendwie da vergräbst du dich in meinen Augen auf eine viel zu kleinen Ebene des Fraktals.
Das äh äh weil weil das äh die Gesamtsituation halt schon so so unglaublich,
äh unbefriedigend ist. Ja und was kommt am Ende auch noch raus, ja? Die ganze Koffpass-Geschichte, ja, haben sie ursprünglich gedacht, ja, zwei Komma sieben Millionen kann das kosten. Jetzt sind sie bei zehn5,4.
Den ganzen Koffpasskram.
Also für das gesamte Zertifikatssystem auch die Ausgabe der Zertifikate.
Nee, nee, nee. Moment, jetzt gucken wir mal. Ähm.
Fünfmal so teuer wie geplant. 15,4 Millionen Euro kosten der digitale Impfnachweis-Kopfpass und die damit verbundenen Cloud-Dienste, das Gesundheitsministerium und damit deutlich mehr als ursprünglich vorgesehen.
Lalala, ursprünglich gibt haben sie zwei Komma sieben gesagt, jetzt sind sie bei 15,4.
Äh weißt du, woran das liegt?
An der agilen Softwareentwicklung und aufgrund der Ergebnisse der Bestimmung, der Abstimmung mit dem Bundesbeauftragten für den Datenschutz und die Informationsfreiheit sowie dem Bundesamt für die Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik waren zusätzliche Entwicklungsleistungen erforderlich. Also, das BSI ist schuld,
Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte und die agile Softwareentwicklung. Ich bitte euch, meine lieben Freunde, das heißt einfach nur, dass ihr diese dass ihr Sicherheit und Datenschutz vorher nicht berücksichtigt habt und jetzt jetzt schieben sie,
ein Kalkulationsfehler von Faktor fünf auf den Arm Ulrich Kälber und auf das BSI, das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein. Also was sind das denn für.
Für Vögelein.
Man hätte einfach alles auf die CWA äh schicken sollen und das war halt auch so ein bisschen dieses Einknicken vor vor diesem,
gefühlten Volkszorn, ne, so oh, die blöde CWA, die uns alle überwacht und so. Ich meine, die Diskussion ist ja mittlerweile auch äh weg. Zurecht ähm ja. Warum macht man dann halt noch so eine Koffpass App?
Warum? Warum sagt man nicht einfach all things Corona CBA.
Nee, weil äh das von IBM kam und die haben natürlich gesagt, na ja, da möchten wir natürlich auch eine Referenzimplementierung machen.
Die schreiben ja nicht in ihr komische fünf Blockchain Scherze äh runter und machen keine Referenz implementierung.
Verstehst? Hättest du auch nicht gemacht so und dann zack hast du eine neue App. So läuft das und wahrscheinlich haben äh IBM und festbekommen, weil sie dachten auch zwei Komma sieben, da ist aber günstig.
Können wir machen. 2,7 Millionen ist super. Für 2,7 Millionen äh schreiben uns die,
Telekom und SAP irgendwie gar kein Angebot. Wir haben die auch mal gefragt. Ah die wollten weißt du? Also es ist einfach wirklich katastrophal. Äh also die die Plan- und Strategielosigkeit,
tropft hier überall raus, ne.
Ja okay, also sagen wir mal so, mit so Kosten äh Punkten wie irgendwas hat 15 Millionen Euro gekostet. Im Rahmen dieser Pandemie.
Mir ist das egal.
Nee, ich setze mich damit auch nicht groß auseinander, weil das das sind keine nennenswerten Kosten im Vergleich zu dem, was wir insgesamt.
Was wir davon haben? Äh ich meine, in einer Welt, in der die meisten Leute, die am am Eingang einer Kneipe stehen, QR-Code-Scanner im in die Iris eingebaut haben, sind natürlich 5zehn ,vier Millionen Euro ein Klacks. So, das ist nämlich der nächste Punkt, ja, den wir.
Das ist wirklich ein interessanter evolutionärer Schritt, ist mir auch aufgefallen. Also da Respekt vor diesen Leuten.
Ich habe ja, ich hatte ja gerade schon erwähnt, dass ich da diesen Vortrag in Wien hatte und da da ist es dann das erste Mal passiert, dass dass ich das oder ich glaube irgendein Hotel wurde auch schon mal meinen Impfausweis äh ordnungsgemäß gecheckt,
ähm also man kann ja gegen die Özils sagen, was man will, ne, aber,
Militär am Flughafen Wien. Die wissen, wie man in dem Ausweis kennt. Das haben sie hingekriegt. So, da stört mich halt einfach Militär,
bumm hier Ausweis zack. Ausweis gucken, hat er auch wirklich geguckt, ja? Ist gesehen, dass er auch wirklich nochmal den Namen abgeglichen hat und ähm,
Ja, die haben sich äh die haben sich äh äh gekümmert, ja.
Ja, das hat auch in der Schweiz äh funktioniert und äh das funktioniert auch in Spanien ganz hervorragend.
Nein, ich äh es funktioniert nicht. Ich hab's ich hab's doch damals schon gesagt, dass niemand diese Scheißdinger ernsthaft kontrolliert
so. Weil die Leute, die an der Tür stehen
in der Regel nicht den Anreiz haben. Wir beide kennen natürlich verantwortungsbewusste Gastronominen, die vor allem keinen Bock haben, irgendwelche Querdenker-Nazis bei sich im Laden zu haben und das auch als willkommene Möglichkeit nutzen.
Ja, äh für Zucht und Ordnung zu sorgen, aber in Berlin ist mir nicht bekannt, dass es jemals vom Ordnungsamt irgendwelche Kontrollen gegeben hätte.
Kann sein, dass es die gab, aber ich weiß davon nichts. Gleichzeitig, ne, was was äh berichten unsere Freundinnen aus der Gastronomie, die es ordentlich machen, ja, irgendwie so.
Was sagtest du? Zehn, fünfzehn Prozent.
Mit einem gelben Lappen an.
Ja, was ich ja erstaunlich finde fast so und also zehn, zehn, fuffzehn also zehn von mir aus, ist ja in Ordnung. Kommen sie mit einem gelben Lappen an, haben halt kein Handy oder so, ne, aber ähm.
Die die die Sache ist ja, was ist die Reaktion darauf, wenn du sagst, zeig mal ausweist, ne? Das ist ja im Prinzip der der Punkt, ab dem es äh haarig wird, weil ein,
einen Impfpass äh zu also ein ein QR-Code in seinem Handy zu haben, ist ja unglaublich einfach. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das in der letzten Sendung gesagt habe, wie ich auf mein neues iPhone umgezogen bin.
Erzählt.
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ein neues iPhone, äh Corona-Warn-App. Denke ich so, okay, ist alles umgezogen, ist ja haarige Angelegenheit die ganzen zweiten Faktoren und so weiter, ne. Corona-Warn-App auf, kein Impfzertifikat drin.
Ach Shit ey, jetzt Impfzettifikat neu importieren. Wie mache ich denn das, ja? Habe ich den Zettel noch irgendwo, ne? Und dann habe ich einfach meinen mein altes iPhone genommen. Hat Corona Warnapp aufgemacht und habe mir das Impfzertifikat anzeigen lassen. Wie zur Prüfung, ja?
QR-Code gescannt, zack war das im neuen Handy. Also, möchtest du ein, möchtest du in der Corona-Warnapp ein, im einen Impfzertifikat haben?
Reicht es im Prinzip zu irgendeiner Person zu gehen und zu sagen, lass mal dein Impfzertifikat kontrollieren und die Corona-Warn-App importiert ist unmittelbar.
Nicht nur die, auch die App macht es genauso.
So und dass die nicht einen, dass die nicht in den Präsentations-QR-Code noch einen Fleck reinmachen, unsigniert und sagen, ich ich zeige das hier übrigens gerade zum Check und nicht zum Import, ne. Das ist ja das soweit kann's ja wohl mal eben nur mitdenken.
Man hätte auch so weit mitdenken können, dass die Corona-Warn-App auch äh einfach die Daten mit umziehen lässt, weil das ist eine explizite Entscheidung äh der Entwickler gewesen. Diese Zertifikate nicht ins Backup reinzutun.
Da kann's aber wahrscheinlich gibt's vielleicht irgendeinen Punkt, dass die Angst haben, dass das Backup dann in der Eye Cloud ist und sie nachher Ärger haben, weil sie Medizinaldaten in die gegeben hat. Weiß ich nicht, warum sie das gemacht haben.
Es ist Unsinn, weil ich meine dieses Zertifikat ist dazu da, dass du das überall hochlädst und zeigst und äh äh Leuten zum Scannen freigibst.
Nee, eben nicht. Der steht spezifisch dran, dass das niemand speichern darf. Also da bin ich mir nicht so sicher T.
Speichern darf. Du musst es äh du musst es, wenn du ins Ausland fliegst, musst du's irgendwie auf zahlreichen Webseiten hochladen.
Niemand darf das speichern. Das ist in der in dieser EU-Verordnung drin.
Ey, ich sage dir, ich ich bin nach Spanien gefahren, da musst du das Ding hochladen. Du fährst nach Israel, musst du das Ding hochladen.
Ja dann haben sie's, dann dann löschen sie es danach.
Ja klar, aber du du musstest die ganze Zeit machen. Und es gab ja noch nicht mal am Anfang eine Funktion, um überhaupt das Zertifikat als Dateie exportierbar zu machen. Das war ja auch noch das Problem. Da mussten die Leute Screenshots äh anfertigen et cetera.
Ja ich wiederhole mich, das darf man nicht speichern. Die Kontrollierenden dürfen es nicht speichern
Und ich vermute, dass der Anlass für für die Entwickler der Corona-Warne das nicht in das Backup zu tun ist, dass sie äh irgendwie wahrscheinlich gesagt bekommen haben, das sind hier medizinische Daten und dass sie die nicht,
die äh potentielle Juristin von Apple da schieben wollten. Das ist mein Verdacht.
Ja, es ist auch mal das ist wahrscheinlich sogar der Grund, aber es ist halt Quatschgrund.
Das mag sein. Ähm was man aber auf jeden Fall hätte verhindern können, ist das eine ganz normale App, die
bei einer Situation, die einer Kontrolle gleicht, äh es dir ermöglicht, das Zertifikat zu importieren, weil der das Argument, was ich eigentlich machen möchte, ist, jede Person kann sofort einen funktionierenden QR-Code in,
in der Corona-Warnapp oder Koffpass-Check-App haben, indem sie einfach von jemand anderem das abscannt. Und das ist auch das, was äh mir zumindest berichtet wird, dass das inzwischen die Versuche sind
sodass die Kontrolleurinnen, mit denen ich so gesprochen habe, inzwischen quasi wenn da eine Gruppe kommt, sich beim Check,
Check-App auch immer die Namen kurz nochmal anschauen, ja, weil eben davon auszugehen ist, dass wenn da jetzt jemand mit einem gefälschten
oder mit einem kopierten QR-Code ankommt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit natürlich noch gegeben ist, dass dass die Person, von der sie die Kopie benutzt, eventuell noch mit dabei ist. Und bei denen, wo's ihnen komisch vorkommt, fragen sie dann halt nach dem Ausweis, ja, oder diese nicht kennen
Ja, fragen sie dann halt nach dem Ausweis. Und dann gibt's eben die Leute, die Reis ausnehmen.
Ende vom Lied, worauf ich eigentlich hinaus möchte. Ich habe es damals vorhergesagt und es wird sich auch nicht ändern, dass die ähm,
dass diese 2G-Regelung mit der Kontrolle von ähm Impfpässen ähm.
Sinnvoll wirkt, weil es zu einfach ist, sich einen augenscheinlich okayen Impfpass ähm.
Irgendwie zu verschaffen, der eine übliche Kontrolle übersteht, wenn du ihn selbstbewusst vorzeigst,
Flugreisen, Hotel-Check-Ins und besonders strenge Kneipen mögen die Ausnahme sein, aber wir sprechen ja hier von,
muss ja der Effekt muss ja immer groß genug sein, um auch eine epidemiologische Wirkung zu entfalten, weißt du? Und das halte ich für ähm unwahrscheinlich, dass.
Du dieses Ausmaß erlangst, ja? Man kann immer sagen, man kann es richtig machen, aber die gelebte Praxis wird nicht dieses Ausmaß erlangen.
Und jetzt kannst du darauf reagieren, indem du sagst, okay, dann müssen wir die gelebte Praxis halt mal müssen wir der gelebten Praxis mal auf die Beine helfen.
Äh saß zum Beispiel alles klar, ich ähm äh,
mache jetzt äh äh ich bestrafe jetzt diejenigen, ne? Ich gehe jetzt, ich gehe durch die Kneipen und wenn ich da irgendjemanden raushole, der nicht einen ordentlichen Impfausweis hat, dann zahlt die Person 500 und der laden 1000 und und schon haben
haben die Kneipen, ne, ein paar Horror Horrorgeschichten gelesen und machen äh was wir ihnen äh was wir ihnen sagen. Das wäre die eine Möglichkeit.
Ähm gleichzeitig bin ich aber irgendwie äh,
sowieso langsam denke ich mir, denke ich darüber nach und da wollte ich eigentlich drauf hinaus. Du hast ja äh schon seit, weiß nicht, wie lange sagst du das jetzt?
Auf jeden Fall über einem Jahr mit Verlosungen zu arbeiten, ne? Einmal bei der Verwendung von der CWA und und auch bei der bei der Impfung war das eine positive Anreize, waren, glaube ich, auch immer etwas, was du bei bei UKW gerne,
gefordert hast.
Und ich würde mich dem inzwischen ähm sehr sehr stark anschließen und zwar ist mein Vorschlag pro Impfung ein Fuffi.
Cash.
Ja, kann man auch überlegen.
Die Überlegung ist eine relativ einfache. Ähm und das ich habe ja Psychologie studiert
und äh durfte mich ja sehr damit auseinandersetzen so mit Anreizen, ne? Wie motiviert man Verhalten
und was sehr viele Leute, also was äh der sehr viel gescholten, ne? Aber was was sehr viele Leute nicht
immer noch nicht verstanden haben, obwohl es hiermit
Fehler und so die die Nobelpreise hier für Nutch und Grudge und solche Geschichten gibt, ja? Dass du mit positiven Anreizen immer sehr viel besser verhalten, motivieren kannst, als du es durch negative Anreize äh motivieren oder demotivieren kannst.
Ja? Also es ist immer besser.
Äh oder du hast bessere Lernerfolge und bessere Ergebnisse mit positiven Anreizen, egal in welche Richtung du gehst. Und,
Ähm wenn man jetzt sagen würde, alles klar, für eine Impfung Fuffi?
Ne, dann hast du zumindest schon mal die Leute, klar, es gibt immer noch die Verschwörungstheoretiker, die dann sagen, jetzt wollen sie uns kaufen, ne, das das gibt's auch, ja? Äh die die aber sowieso nicht los, aber wenigstens möchtest du mal,
Die Anzahl der Ungeimpften wenigstens auf die Verschwörungstheoretiker und Vollidioten reduzieren.
Und ich denke tatsächlich, wir haben ja hier auch vor einiger Zeit noch darüber gelacht, dass äh dass dass sie da irgendwo die Leute mit einer Bratwurst geholt haben und das ein Erfolg war.
Weil die äh aus irgendwelchen Gründen halt dachten, alles klar, da gibt's noch ein Mittagessen dazu, dann passt das, ne. Da muss ich kann ich das irgendwie vielleicht ökonomisch rechtfertigen oder von der Zeit her rechtfertigen, dass ich in einer Zeit, wo ich, was weiß ich, vielleicht sonst bei der
Tafel in der Schlange stehe oder arbeite oder meinem Kind etwas koche, weil ich äh nicht essen fertig kaufe üblicherweise, dass ich jetzt sage, alles klar, wir machen den Ausflug, stellen uns da in die Schlange und kriegen eine Bratwurst.
Ist ja eine ökonomische Realität für Menschen, über die auch wir,
halt damals noch gelacht haben, weil weil wir irgendwie natürlich denken, dass die Impfung so ungefähr das das wünschenswerte und Erstrebenswerteste ist, was was es gab.
Für bestimmte Leute ist das ja auch so.
Für für viele Leute ist das so und sollte das auch so sein. Da gibt's eben Leute, denen musst du das noch erklären. Und jetzt leben wir aber leider, wenn wir jetzt sagen, pro Impfung Fuffi, weißt du, was dann nämlich kommt? Dann melden sich diese 65 Prozent Geimpften und sagen, ja, wo ist denn mein Fuffi?
Ja, das ist in der Tat ein Problem.
Und dann will ich halt sagen, den kriegst du zum Booster. Zu Booster kriegst du einen Fuffi da.
Tja, na ja, also das ist in der Tat jetzt äh das Problem, dass ähm,
Ein bisschen spät kommt, ne? Das ist aber wiederum der Vorteil der Verlosung. Da äh stellst du halt quasi nur eine mögliche Zahlung in Aussicht, aber muss nicht äh alle zwangsläufig abdecken, ne.
Beim beim Fusion Festival haben wir äh ja auch sogar noch Impfungen angeboten, ne.
Um um um auch die Schwelle zu äh runterzusetzen und halt Nugget Möglichkeiten zu geben. Wann bist du mit deinen Freundinnen und Freunden PCR getestet aufm Festival? Ja und dann stehst du da irgendwie und sagst,
Komm Kalle, jetzt kannst du hier noch schnell die Impfung,
ne, aufm aufm beim Rausfahren noch eben schnell rein. Und ich denke, also niedrigschwellige Angebote mit positiver ähm,
Mit positivem Anreiz sind das, was jetzt noch äh die die Verhaltenswissenschaften im Angebot hätten, um äh die Impfquote,
noch hochzubringen und was ich auch noch äh interessant finde ist äh das werdet ihr sicherlich auch in UKW behandeln. Wenn du dir hier mal diese Zahlen anschaust, also wir haben ja jetzt, was haben wir Inzidenz? 2hundert60 oder sowas, ne?
Und äh dann gibt's hier diese schönen Auseinandernehmungen äh es RKI gibt ja dir nur so eine Grundinzidenz an und hier habe ich diese schöne Grafik Frank Rieger hat die getwittert, aber die kriegst du eigentlich jeden Tag nochmal von anderen Leuten auch äh getwittert.
Ähm und zwar unterschieden nach Altersgruppen und ähm Impfstatus. Und unter den Geimpften,
Hast du irgendwie Inzidenzen um und unter 50? Und bei den Ungeimpften hast du halt Inzidenzen inzwischen 4hundert und vier50.
Entschuldigung, zwischen 300 und 450 je nach Alters äh Klasse. Und ähm jetzt sind natürlich
die Altersklassen sind natürlich konfundiert mit
der Impfquote generell, also bei den 60 Jahre ungeimpft, hast du die geringste Inzidenz, was aber daran liegt, dass du natürlich unter den, also 60 plus Jahre, dass du unter den 60 plus Leuten aufgrund der frühen Impfungen sehr viele
Geimpfter Hass und jetzt bei den 12 bis 17 Jahre ungeimpft hast du die höchste Inzidenz, was aber natürlich daran liegt, dass du
insgesamt unter den Zwölf- bis Siebzehnjährigen noch nicht genug geimpfte Hass. Ja, die Geimpften zwischen zwölf und siebzehn. Da liegt die Inzidenz irgendwo bei zehn oder zwanzig.
Und das könnte man den Leuten durchaus mal ähm öfter äh zeigen, ne.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, die Leute sind schon so viele Zahlen, Tabellen und Charts äh gezeigt worden. Da ist natürlich eine totale äh Ermüdung am Start. Da erreicht man jetzt irgendwie,
so sehr viel, aber kurz gesagt, es ist halt einfach so, impfen hilft irgendwie. Wir müssen uns jetzt alle impfen und umso länger noch Leute, die impferei
aussitzen riskieren sie halt ihr und vor allem das Leben anderer Leute und sorgen unmittelbar dafür, dass diese ganze Scheiße sich noch weiter verlängert. So, also ich denke, dieser Witter ist dann weitergehend auch,
gelaufen so, hätte das hätte schon sehr viel anders laufen können, ist aber nicht so.
Anreize ja ich bin gespannt. Also ich bin vor allem gespannt ob die neue Bundesregierung in irgendeiner Form Bock hat,
Pandemie noch irgendwas zu tun. Meiner Meinung nach äh wird das nicht der Fall sein.
Das ist ja im Prinzip, das hat sich ja im Frühjahr schon gezeigt. Ich meine, da haben sie ja die Waffen gestrickt, ne? Die haben einfach gesagt, wir setzen jetzt einfach aufs Impfen, äh alles andere machen wir nicht mehr, weil wir nicht äh die die Möglichkeit sehen,
irgendwelche Maßnahmen,
durchzusetzen, wo es auch nur ansatzweise irgendwie Widerstand dagegen gibt. Wenn man das halt einfach gegen diese ganze Leugnerbande äh von vornherein eingeknickt und das kriegst du jetzt auch kaum noch eingefangen.
Kannst du nicht einfach äh wieder alles hochdrehen, sondern hätte einfach von vornherein den Druck hochhalten sollen und dann langsam absenken, aber,
klar, äh es war halt einfach politische Operturn irgendwie laut Freiheit, Freiheit zu rufen und jetzt haben wir halt den Salat und jetzt müssen wir da irgendwie durch. Insofern kann ich auch noch mal sagen, Leute, holt euch eure Booster Impfung ab,
ja, trinkt drauf, macht es so schnell, wie es irgendwie geht. Ich weiß, nicht jeder hat so ohne Weiteres die Möglichkeit, äh weil Impfzentren geschlossen werden, ist ja.
Ganzen Impfzentren geschlossen sind, jetzt wo wir irgendwie mal eben das Ganze ganze Volk nochmal durchimpfen müssen, so
Und ich verstehe auch nicht, warum man nicht äh gleich sagt so ja ach Impfzentren, geile Idee, komm, dann machen wir Grippeimpfung auch gleich noch mit dazu. So auf so Ideen
irgendwie überhaupt gar nicht. Ja, stattdessen hast du dann so eine schreiende Ärzteschaft, die am Anfang so die Impfzentren, die machen's aber Konkurrenz, wir können das ja viel besser und jetzt so och, das ist ja aber total viel Arbeit irgendwie. Kommen wir ja
gar nix mehr. So, super, geiler äh geile Aktion. Also alle äh sind hilflos und jetzt müssen wir es leider nochmal ausbaden.
Das ist auch ja.
Verkackt. Also sorry, haben wir halt einfach verkackt und jetzt äh ist es halt noch mal schlimm.
Nicht haben wir halt einfach verkackt. Haben wir wissentlich sehenden Auges.
Ja, ja, das ist ja.
Ja? Äh und es es es wäre so ein und und und inzwischen kannst du dir irgendwie Portugal, Spanien oder so was? Hm, easy.
Kannst du ja mal und Deutschland im europäischen Vergleich anschauen. Und ich sage das ganz ehrlich, hätte ja überhaupt kein Problem damit. Also.
Erstens, warum warum äh machen wir diese Impfgegner so Sorgen? Weil ich denke, eine Person, die sich bei einer tödlichen Pandemie nicht impfen lässt, da will ich nicht wissen, was die sich als nächstes einfallen lässt. Ja? Das ist wirklich,
schwierig. Zweitens, ich hätte überhaupt gar kein Problem damit, die, wenn sie ihre, die machen ja individuelle Risikoabwägungen.
Wir sagen ja okay, also für mich ist die ich ich habe jetzt hier mit meiner mit meinen Mathematik-Kenntnissen festgestellt, dass das Risiko einer Impfung mir zu groß ist,
und äh dass ich daher lieber eine äh Infektion riskiere, ja? Okay, dann finde ich das auch überhaupt,
nicht schlimm, wenn dieses Risiko für sich für die Leute manifestiert, weil sie haben sich ja offenbar informiert dafür entschieden, dieses Risiko einzugehen. Dummerweise
hängen die dann auf unseren Intensivstationen und die äh die die Charité hatte jetzt schon gesagt, so dass sie äh planbare OPs jetzt absagen, ne und verschieben, weil sie damit rechnen.
Dass sie die Hütte voll haben, um die ganzen ungeimpften Spinner äh am Leben zu halten.
Aber Lino ist ganz ehrlich, was fällt dir überhaupt ein über Sachen zu reden, die überhaupt gar nicht in deinem Kompetenzbereich liegen? Wir müssen auch über Netzpolitik reden und nur über Netzpolitik.
Stimmt, die haben wir jetzt auch wieder bald. Die haben wir jetzt auch. Stimmt, okay, mach mal, hast recht. Ähm NSO der Hersteller von Pegasus,
der der Schadsoftware, die ja gegen Aktivisten, Journalisten ähm und äh äh Staats äh ähm also hier wie heißt sie, Diplomatinnen und so weltweit eingesetzt wurde?
Und jetzt ja zuletzt dann auch gegen den äh Kolumnisten und Journalisten bei der Washington Post und insgesamt 16 andere journalistische Organisationen weltweit. Ähm.
Wurde jetzt von der von den USA auf die Entity-List gesetzt. Das ist eine Blacklist.
Wo gesagt wird, wir wir äh sagen dieses Unternehmen darf keine amerikanischen Technologien bekommen.
Äh das ist äh äh relativ
interessant, also ich äh mein, wenn du auf dieser Blacklist bist, das ist halt wie so eine Ausfuhrkontrolle, ne, also üblicherweise aber das ist nicht die Ausführkontrolle, was ja ein israelisches Unternehmen und sie haben,
die offenbar auch ein also damit geht sicherlich auch eine Einfuhrkontrolle einher. Aber vor allem sagen sie, also niemand,
aus den USA kann mehr diese äh mit diesem Unternehmen im Geschäft treten,
wenn quasi Technologie zu denen geht. Also wenn du wenn die sagen, ey, wir möchten die irgendwas von dir kaufen, äh wir würden ein iPhone oder so, ja, äh dann dann ist es quasi genehmigungsfähig, dass du denen etwas gibst.
Ja? Ähm,
immerhin schon mal so echt krass, wenn die USA gegen dich eine äh quasi eine eine Sanktion verhängen und das ist sicherlich auch mal ein relativ,
wichtiger Schritt und ja eine, ich meine, gut, die deutsche Bundesregierung gibt denen halt lieber Geld, ähm.
Weißt du was der Hass?
Ist schon erstaunlich, ne? Also ich freue mich, wie das in Israel auch äh ankommt, ne.
Ich als ich mein es ist,
schon wirklich relativ klar, dass jetzt irgendwie dass bei der NSO Group mit diesem Pegasus Produkt jegliche moralischen Standards äh äh Vergebens gesucht werden.
Ne und dass das eben nun mal ja äh die Bösen sind,
äh die für die Bösen arbeiten und gegen unsere Interessen. So, das ist äh denke ich sehr klar äh dargestellt und ähm ja es ist schön, dass es die die USA äh wenigstens eingesehen haben.
Spannend ist auch, es gab eine äh wieder eine ganze Reihe an Wear Angriffen, diese,
Woche allein, Mediamarkt Saturn hat irgendwie eine Forderung, ich glaube im hohen Millionenbereich und dann wurde noch ein Unternehmen,
gehackt mit dem Namen Medatics. Ja? Die ähm irgendwie.
Potenziell Thematik Infrastruktur-Passwörter dort könnten gezockt worden sein,
Also wir haben jetzt hier quasi in einem großen Telematik-Anbieter ein Fall und Rancing Wear ist ja inzwischen.
Äh nicht mehr nur die Drohung mit äh der also das das Verschlüsseln von Daten und das Erpressen von Geld, um die wieder zu entschlüsseln, sondern auch die Drohung mit der Veröffentlichung.
Von Daten. Medatic sagt ja, nee, der war, Angriff war nur gegen uns, nicht gegen unsere Kunden.
Praxisverwaltungssysteme sind nicht betroffen, aber sagen Änderung eure Passwörter. Was auch hier irgendwie wie ein relativ äh schlechterer, also irgendwie so
Ja, was können wir machen? Äh die sollen ihre Passwörter ändern. Warum sollen die ihre Passwörter ändern? So habt ihr die nicht gehasht oder was? So, also es ist irgendwie hm,
äh schwierig, so dass scheint mir scheint mir nicht kompetent äh äh scheint mir kein kompetenter Rat zu sein.
Besteht besteht keine Gefahr, seien Sie ganz beruhigt, aber setzen Sie bitte Ihre Sauerstoffmasken auf.
Genau, jetzt nicht mal ihre Sauerstoffmaske auf und äh ähm gehen sie in die aber erst kurz bevor wir einschlagen, dann besteht zu keinem Zeitpunkt eine Gefahr für die Bevölkerung, ja?
Wenn wir auf dem Wasser landen, dann gehen Sie bitte gesittet zum Ausgang,
des zerborsten Flugzeugs? Ja okay, dann lassen wir das. Ähm der äh was was eigentlich die Nachricht ist, ich äh finde ja sehr interessant.
Wie die USA,
sich jetzt in diesen ganzen Bereich positionieren. Zunächst einmal hatte Biden ja vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten schon angekündigt, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, pass mal auf, wir nehmen das jetzt hier ernst und wir schließen.
Ähm militärische Gegenschläge oder militärische Konsequenzen aus Hacking-Angriffen nicht mehr aus. Ja? Das ist ein sehr also eine sehr klare Ankündigung in der zwei Dinge mitschwingen. Erstens,
Wir schließen militärische Konsequenzen nicht mehr aus und zweitens aber auch, wir, die USA,
ja? Urheber äh von Stucksnäht äh und äh Facebook und Google und wie die ganzen Tools des Stick der der strategischen Kriegsführung heißen, ja? Ähm.
Können uns dagegen nicht wehren und
sagen und weiten deshalb aus auf unser Abschreckungsarsenal äh mit U-Booten und äh Raketen und das und äh was wir nicht alles haben, ja? Das ist ein ein bemerkenswerter Schritt,
der natürlich auch bedeutet, dass die in diesem Bereich der IT-Sicherheit sich nicht helfen können.
Das ist relativ krass. Jetzt haben sie außerdem etwas gemacht. Sie haben auf die verantwortliche äh auf die Verantwortlichen hinter äh Reville.
Also einer Gruppe ähm.
Zehn Millionen US-Dollar Kopfgeld ausgesetzt und fünf Millionen für Hinweise, die zur Verhaftung oder Verurteilung von äh zum Beispiel Associats gelten, also Leute, die
für Review Infektionen machen. Review sind die, hinter diesem Angriff, ne? Dieser Managementplattform für ähm
Managed Services, ja.
Außerdem haben sie für die Darksidebande äh die den Hack auf die Colonial Pipeline durchgeführt hatten. Äh Kopfgelder ausgelegt oder ausgelobt und das ist natürlich,
tatsächlich keine so blöde Methode, denn ähm,
Bunden, ihr habt das ja, glaube ich, schon öfter betont, die haben relativ hohe Abhängigkeiten, ja? Die müssen ihre
Bitcoins oder sonstigen Dinge waschen, ne. Du hast die die üblichen Abhängigkeiten eines äh hauptberuflichen Verbrechers, was also vertrauete angeht, was Geldwäsche angeht, ähm ne? Du kannst nicht einfach nur im verborgenen agieren und niemand weiß es. Ja, du hast
immer mehr Abhängigkeiten. Und wenn du wahr ist,
äh dass dass du zehn Millionen US-Dollar auf deinem Kopf hast, ne, dann wird es sehr, sehr schwierig noch Leuten zu vertrauen.
Weil äh deine die Luft wird halt relativ dünn. Und äh du arbeitest ja im rechtsfreien Raum,
ähm und das kann natürlich echt verführerisch sein für deine ähm Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Braucht nur einer einer zu sagen so auch so zehn Millionen irgendwie äh ziehe ich jetzt aus dieser Unternehmung nicht raus. Die anderen, die holen sich gerade irgendwie die Kohle, dann macht doch einfach mal mich selber auch unangreifbar, ne? Ist ja so,
sondern auch gleich noch äh wahrscheinlich irgend so eine Kronzeugenregelung auch noch mit drin, ne? Genau,
alle verpettze, komme ich dann davon. Und das ist natürlich dann äh etwas, was so ein soziales Gefüge in so einer Crime-Bande schnell auseinander bringt.
Nicht zu verachten sind trotzdem die ermittlerischen äh äh die Ermittlungserfolge in diesem Bereich ähm.
Die wir hier schon regelmäßig auch äh gelobt haben.
Dann kommen wir zu dem Thema, auf das wahrscheinlich alle gewartet haben. Ähm und zwar wurde äh die Webseite von Attila Hildmann mal wieder gehackt.
Äh allerdings äh ja auf einem gewissen Umweg, ich gucke mal gerade ganz kurz. Attila Hildmann DE. Ist auch immer noch down.
Und ich war heute Morgen.
Mit einem Journalisten, der sich mit Attila Hildmann sehr auseinandergesetzt hat.
Die neue Seite ja der es ist wirklich also Attila Hildmann DE ist down, aber der hat jetzt eine neue ein neues Block ja.
Die Domain, ich ich lass jetzt mal die Top-Level-Domaine weg. Ja, weil für so was muss man nicht auch noch Traffic generieren. Aber der Domainname ist AH achtzehn.
Freiheit und Wahrheit für alle Völker.
Alter ist keine Diä.
Ja, ich meine der ist komplett entrückt, der Typ.
Der ist vollständig durch, ja.
Und na ja, was also genau, verlinken wir nicht und äh hm gibt's auch eh nur äh Quatsch zu sehen. Jetzt, was ist Attila Hildmann passiert?
Leaks, ja, also äh die Operation tinvoll äh ist ja wirklich eine äh sehr erfolgreiche Operation,
von und äh deren äh äh Meldungen haben wir hier regelmäßig behandelt. Äh hat also sich entschieden, dass sie gerne at Attila Hildmann DE hacken möchten.
Und ähm,
Dann haben sie geguckt, okay, wo ist denn das Ding gehostet und haben festgestellt, ähm wo dieser wo dieser Hoster ist, ja und zwar ist das bei dem Unternehmen Prosite, das ist die Hosting Marke von Speedball und Internet,
and Connectivity, ja? Ein relativ kleiner Hoster, die eben in Berlin einen Rechenzentrum haben.
Und in diesem Rechenzentrum kannst du Co-Location haben, also kannst du Sachen ins Track stellen, kannste von den Sachen,
mieten oder eben äh kannst bei denen quasi so eine Art managed äh Seite bestellen, ja? Also wo du sagst, okay, ich will.
Ich brauche einen Block, gib mal, ja? So, jetzt haben die äh,
gesehen, okay, bei Attila Hildmann DE finden wir keine Schwachstelle. Also gucken wir uns doch mal,
den Rest an ja also die in dem gleichen IP-Adressbereich kannst du dir ja angucken wem der welcher IP-Adressbereich die haben, was es da so angeboten was da so angeboten wird.
Und finden eine äh Webseite mit einer etwas älteren Installation.
Und knacken halt dieses Juuler. Juuler ist so ein Content Management System, ich glaube ist das in PRP auch geschrieben, oder?
Ja, ist PAP.
Ähm ein ein äh Content Management System.
Mit äh das also hier auf dem Webserver läuft und üblicherweise ist das so, du du hast also dann ja V-Server, also,
du kannst durchaus unterschiedliche,
Serverangebote auf so einem Einzelserver laufen lassen, wo wenn du einfach dafür sorgst, dass halt die Dateien in dem Web-Rout ähm immer jemand anderem gehören,
und ähm dann quasi schafft es die Multi User
Eigenschaft oder auch so zum Beispiel, wenn das jetzt ein äh BSD ist, äh machst du das halt in einzelnen. Schaffst du es, dass du jetzt mehrere solche Angebote auf einem Server laufen hast?
Auf einem großen Server laufen hast, die aber komplett voneinander gekapselt sind. Ja? Also,
wenn Attila Hildmann auf Attila Hildmann DE zugreift, kann er nicht eine Webseite verändern, die ähm auch auf dem gleichen Server liegt,
so das Ziel, ja? Und das haben die dort auch gemacht, aber dieses.
Lief in der Datenbank, also die läuft auf eine Datenbankserver und da haben sie natürlich auch einen Datenbankserver für alles, ja, ein Datenbankcluster. Als Rot.
Als Rot. Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
So, also in dem, das heißt in dem das irgendein Jummler von irgendeinem Kunden mit irgendeiner Schwachstelle, hatte Hut auf der Datenbank.
So und und zwar nicht nur von von diesem von dieser Julia Installation, sondern von Profit,
Also von allen Kundinnen und Kunden damit eben auch die Datenbank, die sich hinter Attila Hildmann DE befindet, aber auch ähm,
zum Beispiel Zutrittskontrolle zum Rechenzentrum,
Account Verwaltungssystem äh indem man Account sperren kann, Ticketsystem, bei dem Beschwerden Wünsche und Probleme Einkommen,
Klimaregelung des Rechenzentrums Schneiderelektrik äh Klimakühlung, ja? Die Webcams, die quasi das Rechenzentrum filmen,
Das interne Metamorst hängt dadrin, äh die Kundendaten,
Ja und in dem Ticketsystem finden sie dann auch äh die Beschwerde von von Attila Hildmann, dass seine Seite down ist.
Das heißt, die haben diesen kompletten Hoster äh äh auseinandergenommen und äh genau, dann dann finden sie halt die Mail an den Support, ja,
Attila Hildmann Wolf at Protonmail dot com. Domain erneut geraubt, sehr geehrtes Profiteam, ich kann mich nicht mehr einloggen, ja, was ist da passiert? Bitte schnelle,
und die Antworten,
Nonne muss antwortet, das tut mir sehr leid, Mauskuss auf die Nuss. Liebe Grüße, dein Alptraum. Das schreiben die dem von der von info at prosite DE zurück.
Kuss auf die Nuss!
Das heißt, die haben die haben den kompletten die haben dieses komplette Profitding auseinander genommen. Ähm krasse Nummer.
Na ja, ich meine, die haben Sie ja schon selber auseinandergenommen, ne, weil äh so sein System zu designen ist natürlich schon in der Kategorie grob fahrlässig.
Ja, das also äh äh ich das ist äh also du kannst nicht also,
tatsächlich. Egal was du machst, ja, egal welche Anleitung du verfolgst, ähm und ich garantiere dir auch eine Juma-Installationsanleitung.
Da ist als allererstes immer drin, erstelle einen Nutzer,
Erstelle eine Datenbank, gebe dem Nutzer Rechte an dieser Datenbank und trage diesen Nutzername das Passwort in die, was weiß ich, Config PRP ein.
Genau und nur die Rechte, die du brauchst.
Ja, leider, leider, ehrlich gesagt, bei diesen meisten Content Management Systemen nicht, also die die brauchen ja alle Rechte und meistens laufen ja auch tatsächlich nur mit einem Nutzer.
Und der hat dann halt Grand Old Privileges on was weiß ich, Juuler drei fünf acht. User drei fünf acht Identified by Passwort, ja? Ähm,
Also so so funktioniert diese Content Management Systeme, die haben da jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Nutzerinnentrennung, obwohl du das machen könntest, ja? Aber da Ruht einzutragen,
Auf die Idee musst du erstmal kommen,
Also das geht halt gar nicht, ne? Also das geht wirklich nicht. Wenn du wenn du auf irgendeinen Server installierst, dann sagt er dir als allererstes, Achtung, hier ist der Rot-User. Das Nächste, was du machen musst, ist andere User anlegen.
Also man kann es ist wirklich, ich habe nirgendwo etwas gefunden, wo dir wo dir jemand auch nur in die Nähe kommt von Trag in deine Konflikt, ruht ein,
Also es ist wirklich äh unvorstellbarer Fehler, den ich also unvorstellbar. Tja, dann haben sie außerdem noch äh gab's dann eine äh weitere Reaktion,
von einem Twitter-Nutzer, der den Geschäftsführer von Proside recherchiert hat und äh äh feststellt, dass der ähm,
Impfgegner ist, den Content rechtsextremer Websites äh verbreitet und sich für Chemtrails interessiert.
Sieht der aber ganz anders.
Der sieht das natürlich anders, ja? Also er hat irgendwelche, also gibt's dann irgendwie und George, Soros, ist der Strippenzieher und Querdenken und haste alles nicht gesehen.
Programm sozusagen. Er schreibt dazu, damit wollte ich auf keinen Fall die dunkelste Zeit der deutschen Geschichte in irgendeiner Weise verharmlosen oder rechtes Gedankengut vermitteln, sondern meine Besorgnis über die aktuelle Situation zum zu Ausdruck bringen.
Ja äh genau, das Unternehmen hat sich jetzt äh geäußert. Ähm ja.
Ja, da ist äh glaube ich da da kann man nicht mehr sehr viel wegdiskutieren so. Das ist halt einfach.
Nee, nee, das ist.
Wer Attila Hildmann als Kunden äh überhaupt akzeptiert. Ist ja schon ähm sozusagen auf der falschen Seite.
Da bin ich jetzt mal also.
Vorsichtig. Ich weiß nicht genau, seit wann der da ist. Da habe ich einfach eine Wissenslücke, ne? Es kann sein, dass der da ist vor einem Jahr hingezogen ist. Es kann sein, dass der äh seit zwanzig Jahren bei denen ist. Ich weiß es nicht, ne? Keine Ahnung. Hm die,
Es ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert, wenn wir sagen, wir fordern ein Privileg ein.
Und gleichzeitig sagen äh wir äh ne, wir verurteilen die Unternehmen, die mit solchen Leuten äh die solche Sachen hosten, hm.
Und verlangen von denen, dass sie möglichst kein Geld äh dass sie dass sie die rausschmeißen, ja? Ich bin da nicht.
Ne? Ich ich will niemanden entschuldigen, der hat hier Hildmann DE hostet uns auf die paar Mark,
Äh kannst du verzichten und vor allem kannst du dir äh das Interesse von findigen an deiner Netzwerkinfrastruktur auch sparen. Wenn du halt solche Spinner nicht da hast, ne. Gleichzeitig ähm
sage ich mal, wär's unerhört, wenn sich irgendjemand äh sagen würde, was weiß ich, der Neumann ist aber jetzt hier irgendwie,
für die Impfung und deswegen schmeiße ich den raus. Ne, also das ist es ist schwierig, ja.
Gleichzeitig wird's natürlich mit so einem Unternehmen nichts zu tun haben, was äh,
relativ offensichtlich nicht nur gesagt hat, okay wohl oder übel nehmen wir diesen Hildmann auf, sondern offenbar auch äh zumindest der Geschäftsführer.
Äh ähm sehr eindeutig äh diese Inhalte, diese Inhalte gegenüber sehr aufgeschlossen ist, ne.
Ja, also äh ich weiß nicht, da muss man jetzt gar nicht groß drum rum reden. Also ich meine, wer wer im Jahr 2021 im Herbst noch Attila Hildmann hostet, äh,
versteht glaube ich äh nicht, wie die Welt funktioniert. Also das äh geht einfach nicht.
Also das ist einfach dem hätte ich einfach äh geschrieben. Guten Tag, äh es ist uns äh sozusagen ihr Inhalt ist uns hier äh.
Zu Ohren gekommen und ähm wir kündigen jetzt hier einfach mal den Vertrag. Fertig. Tschüss.
Fristgemäß fürs Jahr.
Müssen wir nicht haben.
Offenlegung an dieser Stelle, ähm also äh dieses Unternehmen, Profit ist also, ne, Hosting.
Speedborn hatte ein Rechenzentrum stehen und in diesem Rechenzentrum gibt's auch Colocation und Housing, mit anderen Worten, da kannst du dir Redspace mieten mit Anbindung.
Und.
Also du man kann seinen eigenen Computer da reinstellen, der dann da Internet hat.
Genau und äh dann zahlst du halt für Strom oder sowas, ne? Und wenn ich jetzt sage, dass ich dieses Ding,
Am Albuin-Kontor befindet, dann klingelt bei dir auch eine Glocke.
Ja, ich war da auch schon mal.
Ja, da stehen äh tatsächlich, das kann man an dieser Stelle nicht unerwähnt lassen als äh Colocation, ähm auch Server vom Chaos-Computer-Club
äh Profit schreibt dazu die Netzwerke für Colo Cash und Housing Kunden sind von dem Vorfall unberührt geblieben, da es sich hierbei um einen komplett abgetrennten Bereich handelt. Screenshots der Datenbank mit den Zutrittskarten, die auf der Seite unkenntlich geleakt wurden.
Haben jedoch nichts mit der eigentlichen Zutrittskontrolle zu tun. Hierbei handelt es sich um eine Abrechnungsdatenbank für die Zutrittskarten, der Zugang zum Rechenzentrum ist und war zu keinem Zeitpunkt gesperrt. So,
Chaos-Computer-Club hat da, wie gesagt, äh einige Server stehen und wir schauen uns jetzt gerade mal äh diese Situation an. Ähm,
Welche Alternativen wir denn für diese Server so finden.
Gleichzeitig sei dazu gesagt, äh kann ich an dieser Stelle, es wurde äh bei Golem DE irgendwie sehr hochgejassed. Da war ich auch nicht besonders glücklich mit
der Redaktion auch mitgeteilt, weil die mich irgendwie mehr oder weniger kurz gefragt haben, ich eine kurze Antwort gegeben habe und nicht wusste, dass das jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich,
die Headline wird, dass der Chaos-Computer-Club, wie sicherlich viele andere auch, äh über überdenkt, welche Beziehungen wir da haben, aber äh bei der Infrastruktur, die der Chaos-Computer-Club unterhält,
also der Menge, da kannst du jetzt nicht einfach sagen, übrigens wir kündigen mieten eine Robbe und fahren ins nächste Rechenzentrum, ja? Das heißt, das ist äh sehr viel äh Arbeit und sehr viel Überlegungen, die da ins Haus stehen.
Insofern wird das mit Sicherheit einige Zeit äh in Anspruch nehmen.
Aber wir reden ja jetzt nicht von virtuellen Servern, sondern wir reden halt von real wirklich dort in das in diesen Ort.
Metall. Bares Metall, zwei Regale, glaube ich.
Genau. Reingeschraubte Geräte. Zwei Regale, okay. Ja, da ist halt viel so Media CCDE wahrscheinlich und so, ne? Ja.
Können sogar mehr sein. Also ich ich das ist äh das ist halt auch ne, es gibt ja nicht den CCC, der den Server hat, sondern es gibt
dann halt, ne? Unterschiedliche Teams im CCC, die was weiß ich, seit 20 Jahren der eine den seit soundsoviel Jahren die anderen den und übrigens sind noch drei Recks dazugekommen. Also erstmal den Überblick dazu bekommen,
ist halt in einer dezentralen äh Struktur nicht so einfach. Tja, okay. Dann,
noch kurz zu den Jobs. Ähm unsere Freunde bei suchen,
ein Python oder Ruby Web Developer ne, das ist die NGO die sich im Datenschutz GDP äh einsetzt, der Laden von Max Schrems. Ähm die,
Ausschreibung haben wir verlinkt und Sie haben das als Junior-Position und auch als Advanced äh angeboten, wo Sie also sagen, je nachdem, ne, mit Experience.
Und so äh für die Advanced würden sie sagen, gehen wir bei, starten wir Vollzeit bei 65tausend, das ist
je nachdem kann ich mir schon durchaus vorstellen dürfte, dass äh eine konkurrenzfähige, ein konkurrenzfähiges äh leer sein. Äh ja, schaut's euch mal an. Wenn äh,
Python und Ruby äh euch gefällt und ihr Lust habt, hier bei eben einer doch sehr einflussreichen und schlagkräftigen NGO zu helfen.
So, das bringt uns äh zum letzten Thema.
Ja, einen Termin. Machen wir kurz ohne Musik, oder? Der Winterkongress der digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz.
Der findet statt,
am fünfundzwanzigsten, sechsundzwanzigsten Februar hoffentlich wieder live in der roten Fabrik in Zürich und sie haben jetzt ihren CFP, den Call vor Papers, Call for Patipation, der läuft noch bis zum zweiten,
Dezember,
Dann gibt's auch nach dem CFP gibt's dann auch Tickets, ja? Link zum CFP und die Ankündigung haben wir im äh in den und äh.
Freuen uns auf dieses Event im am 25., 26. Februar hoffentlich live in Zürich.
So, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung, Tim.
So sieht's aus, wird's halt.
Wir haben's grad knapp nach hinten, ne, also du hast es gerade knapp nach hinten, deswegen müssen wir ein bisschen auf die Tube drücken.
Das machen wir und verabschieden uns einfach.
Genau. Ihr wisst ja.
Euch schöne Klamotten, sonst erfriert ihr im Winter. Wenn ihr gesund bleiben wollt, müsst ihr euch warm anziehen.
Und generell, ihr wisst ja, wie die politische Lage ist. Da muss man sich sowieso warm anziehen, also von daher passt das auch ganz gut.
So denn tschau tschau.
Tschüss.